Hello everybody, okaeri na saimasen!
Goshijin-sama, ojou-sama!
Hold on, I gotta do something.
I've been wanting to do this.
And now I have.
Hold on, I remember.
Okay, 3, 2, 1!
Classic.
Oh my goodness.
Classic, classic.
There we go.
Welcome back to Metal Gear Solid 3.
Snake Eater.
For those asking about memory cards, yes, I found another one.
So we're all good.
I put it in and switched it.
Thank you so much for using my art for the thumbnail today!
And on the first Snake Eater stream means a ton!
Of course!
God!
Oh my gosh, thank you!
It's so awesome!
Thank you!
I'm...
Whoa!
What a fear in my heart But your soul's supreme But I'm alive Not for
real In my time There'll be no one Will we get Sneder today?
I wonder.
Oh my gosh you guys, my voice is really dead today.
I love these little guys, these little parachute guys.
I come back.
Parachute.
Parachute guys.
OMG she's playing Delta.
So true.
Oh my god.
Bam.
Damn it.
No Sneder today.
Yippee!
Oh yes.
Welcome back to Metal Gear Solid 3.
Subsistence.
Yeah.
Bye bye Metal Gear Solid 4.
Last time we ended off right before the end fight.
Not the last fight.
Not to be confused with the final fight, but the fight with the boss known as the end.
I'm gonna be honest, I'm not feeling super hot today.
I'm feeling a little under the weather.
So I'm not sure how long I'll play.
Since yesterday I started feeling a little bit icky.
But I don't know.
I might get into it and I might just kinda go for it.
Oh, do you guys want some coffee can ASMR?
Here we go.
Wow, that one is actually pretty clean.
Yeah, I think I've just been kinda overworking myself a little bit.
Yeah, I have a stomach ache.
That was smooth.
That was crisp.
That was so good.
I'm shocked.
Usually that always is like all over me.
Usually.
But... and I tested this earlier.
Ready?
My save... I transferred it over to a new card.
So we should have no problems.
We should be okay.
We should be good.
We should be alright.
Um...
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Yeah, so...
Like I said, we're at the end.
Not at the... of the...
The game.
Sorry, I thought I heard my cat.
I think it was something outside.
Um...
I don't know.
I don't think it's from last night.
I mean, last night definitely didn't help.
For those who don't know, I had a concert.
Like on an aircraft carrier last night.
But...
My voice was even feeling bad before then.
So I think I've just got a little cold, you know.
I think I've got a little cold is all.
So...
Um, yeah.
Yeah.
The USS Hornet.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Saturday on a Minecraft carrier.
Sunday playing MGS3.
It's a military weekend.
Yes, baby!
Yeah, yeah.
Um...
Hmm.
What else was I gonna say?
It's a video of the One Piece song.
Yeah!
Wait, did I say Minecraft?
Oh, I meant aircraft.
No way.
Did I say Minecraft?
Oh my god.
Is
it today?
Oh my god.
No way.
Wait.
Did I actually?
Did I actually say Minecraft?
Aircraft carrier.
Sorry.
Anything with blank craft.
My mind automatically is gonna say Minecraft.
Okay.
Oh, gosh!
So yeah.
Let's get into it.
So I don't know.
Like I said, I'm not sure how long I'll play.
Any VOD watchers?
Hello, hello.
You will know how long I played.
Looking cute in your green tent.
Thank you.
It's very MGS1.
But, you know, it still works, I feel.
Concert on aircraft carrier.
Minto is a true warrior.
So yeah.
Oh!
Snake, are you there?
Eva.
Where are you?
In the fortress.
In Groznygrad.
Groznygrad.
Dr. Sokolov is here too.
Is he alright?
He's fine.
Right now he's busy putting the finishing touches on the shagglehod.
No.
Good.
That means they haven't killed him.
Not yet, Minto.
Sorry for my voice.
They've already finished the phase 2 tests.
Oh no.
Sokolov's preparations are complete.
They'll have no more use for him.
The colonel won't have any qualms about killing him if he thinks the CIA is closing in.
Eva, you can't let Sokolov out of your sight.
I know.
Snake, do you know where Groznygrad is?
What's your favorite picture of Eva?
Granon told me that I should be able to get there from the mountains to the north through an underground tunnel.
That one's pretty nice.
Granon told you?
Yeah.
He even gave me the key to the warehouse.
Yeah, I just went through.
Four.
One.
You've gotta be kidding me.
Four.
Hell if I know.
That's side profile.
Snake, there's one problem with that route.
Five.
What problem?
The mountain entrance to the underground tunnel that leads to the fortress is sealed.
You need a key to get in.
Oh.
A key?
What about the key Granon gave me?
That key won't work.
Why not?
But don't worry.
I'll figure something out.
Why does she say it like that?
That key won't work.
I have an idea.
Okay.
There are some ruins at the top of the mountains.
Meet me there.
Ruins.
The top of the mountains.
Got it.
Ruins.
Wait.
It's like my least favorite area.
I'm gonna be honest.
Now what?
I heard that one of the cobras is waiting for you in the jungle at the foot of the mountains.
The jungle?
He's a legendary sniper called The End.
The End.
Yeah.
I've seen him before.
That ridiculously old guy, right?
Don't underestimate him.
He's so old.
He's known as the father of modern sniping.
Oh my god.
Is he alone?
No spotter?
None.
He's all by himself.
He's got the bird.
Apparently, he doesn't need a spotter.
The bird is here.
The bird is his spotter.
He can't be serious.
The entire forest is on his side.
The forest?
Stay alert.
One with the snow white.
Yeah.
I'd hate to have it be the End for me.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Yeah.
Honestly, I don't remember how to do the End fight at all.
Oh my goodness.
Hold on.
All my food is bad, isn't it?
Call Eva back to have an argument.
Argument.
Argument!
The name of that forest is Svyatogorni, in Russian it means something like the sacred mountain path.
The name comes from an old folk tale about mountain spirits who passed through there on their way to Sokrovieno, the forest to the north.
Head north and you'll come to Sokrovieno.
The tunnel that leads to the mountains is in the northern area of Sokrovieno.
I'll meet you in the ruins at the top of the mountains.
Okay.
I'll give you the key to the tunnel leading to Groznygrad when you get there.
Remember, go north.
Go north.
But Sokrovieno is also where...
I know.
The end, right?
Yeah.
Why did it say, like, suddenly got so, like, serious?
The end is waiting for you in Sokrovieno.
He's a legendary sniper.
The end.
Until you defeat him in battle...
I won't be able to move on.
Right.
Then I'll just have to beat him.
I guess you will.
That wasn't a fight.
Let me try again.
Eva.
What?
I couldn't get a hold of you for a while there.
What were you doing?
Oh, yeah.
What do you think I was doing?
That's what I'm asking you.
Yeah.
Why are you asking me that?
Because I want to know.
That's why.
Want to know what?
Will you stop answering my questions with questions?
Are you mad?
See ya.
What are you mad about, huh?
What are you mad about?
Snake, have you been contacted by Eva?
Maybe.
Yeah.
She said we'd meet up in the ruins at the top of the mountains.
She also said she picked up the key to get into the tunnel that leads to Krasnograd.
Yes.
Have you...
Good.
Hurry to the rendezvous with Eva.
Head for the mountains.
Proceed north through the woods.
If you have your...
Sorry.
I don't know why I waited.
I thought he was done.
If you have your...
Climb up the shaft and you'll come out of the mountains.
I don't know why I waited to keep talking until he started talking again.
Head north.
I'm on it.
But stay on your toes.
My toes.
Isn't the Cobra Unit's sniper lying in wait for you?
If you wait a week...
Yeah.
But there's no other way.
The end will die.
Yes.
Your obsession...
Watch yourself.
Your opponent is a legendary sniper.
Your fight with the end will likely be a long and grueling one.
Your obsession...
You should stock up on battle necessities like ammunition and provisions now while you still can.
No.
I gotta get a gun.
OK.
Thank you, guys.
Boss it's my friend Kay's birthday.
They are a huge fan of yours cause you wished him a happy birthday.
Of course.
Kay, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Kay.
Happy birthday!
Sorry, my voice is a little squeaky today.
Mint, can you help me out?
My 4-year-old daughter loves your streams but she is struggling to count backwards from 10 to 0.
Can you show her how it's done like a boss?
10... 9... wait, okay.
I have to... okay.
We gotta make this like a kid's show.
Wait, no.
What do you mean no?
Not this way.
Where's the trap?
No?
Wait, what's wrong?
Just... don't?
3... 3...
Is it the hawk thing again?
I don't know.
Go away!
Getting your daughter involved in this nonsense.
Boss, can you say you maybe don't hate us?
I'm not taking any more bait.
I'm not taking any more bait, okay?
Gosh.
I don't get it.
I don't know either.
My food is all...
Look, I have... oh no!
My glow caps!
No!
At least all my...
Oh, my rabbit.
We didn't even get to eat it.
Oh, I should have eaten them.
Alright, let's throw it out.
Oh...
My false mango!
What a waste.
We got a lot of food, but... you know.
Yeah.
I don't think there's guys around this area, but let's get some more...
Oh, what's this?
A book.
Let's see.
What can we...
There's something down...
Oh, I think that's a frog.
Oh!
Oops.
Knife.
Get that frog!
Get that frog snake!
Get that...
I'm cutting the grass again.
Get that frog.
Oh, there it is.
I got the frog.
Maybe I should have...
They would have...
They wouldn't eat that, right?
They wouldn't have eaten that, right?
This is a good spot to catch a tsuchinoko.
We don't have to do that today since it's very RNG heavy.
Wait, actually, right here?
Some areas to explore before you go straight north if you want.
Might be a missable weapon.
Good to know.
Thank you.
There's a bunny!
Come here.
This is my snack.
Sorry, bunny.
Guys, this is my snack.
Also, they have serum for some reason.
I don't quite understand why, but...
Guys, I need that.
It's the poop?
Wait, what's up there?
What's up here?
Oh, I can maybe get some...
fruit?
Or...
Where is Kerotan, I wonder?
Waka, waka, waka, waka, waka.
Have fun against the la- Wait, why did that change?
We're not there yet!
I think we can just keep going.
What the?
Did I just hear something hiss at me?
Stop!
Maybe I should...
Hold on.
We'll take this guy.
Oh!
There we go.
Ok, now we got the snake D.
We got the snake D.
It's in my backpack?
Where do you put these guys?
Oh!
Coral Snake!
Yeah...
...
I got the snake D.
A live coral snake.
Will he die in there next week if I don't use him?
What's a ghost's favorite drink?
Booba tea.
Actually,
I'll hold on to it.
Are these berries?
Sea med.
Oh, cold medicine.
What else is in... is there anything else to explore?
Oh, more medicine.
Oh, splint?
What?
Huh?
How?
Okay.
There's a bunny up there.
Snack.
A snack, a snack.
Hello, I'm late.
You're...
Who was that?
You're not late at all.
I just got started.
What's this?
Disinfectant?
Gosh, I need all this stuff, don't I?
Especially right before... this battle.
This fight.
I know for Delta, in the bottom left corner, there's a...
There's a... what's it called?
A compass now.
So, we'll have a compass.
For any...
When they're like, go north, and you're like...
What is north?
Which is me.
I have a little issue with directions sometimes.
Do I want the blablokos or... Nah, I don't need a blabloko.
I think we're okay.
What do you mean, we know?
Stop it, Snack.
West.
I don't remember when it starts, the fight, you know?
I don't remember when he goes heavy, yo.
I don't know when is exactly the beginning.
I can't remember.
A couple areas before then?
Oh, okay.
Are there guys around?
Or are we pretty safe?
I wonder.
Just update my...
My uniform.
Baby corn thinks he's the captain!
Five guys.
Oh, I don't need to change it.
Okay, cool.
There's guys before the end.
Why are there always guys, man?
Why are there always guys?
There we go.
I was like, wait a second, that's not my...
Some moments like this.
I wish I could crouch walk.
I see a beehive.
Is that a beehive or is that a blabloko?
That's a beehive.
I can hear him buzzing.
Where are the guys at?
What's...
Is that a guy?
In there?
I don't think so.
Wow, actually the original camera angle kind of helped here.
Let's see how the original camera angle is throughout this.
Oh, never mind, I hate it.
Okay.
He's like...
Thermal?
Oh, yeah.
Sorry,
I gotta get back into the groove of things, guys.
I gotta get back into the groove of things.
Why is that spot so warm?
Is that a trap?
I hear footsteps somewhere.
Oh!
There he is.
Oh my gosh.
Oh why'd you have to like go behind the tree huh.
Is he coming this way?
Oh my gosh please.
I got him.
No worries.
Anyone else?
Sorry for your eyes?
Everybody?
What if I put him in the mud?
Oh I see him.
Where is he?
Where'd he go?
Mister.
Oh mister.
Oh no that's not what I was doing.
Disappeared.
Hmm.
Let's go to leaf.
I'm just a leaf.
Where the hell did that guy go?
What?
He disappeared from my sight!
Back to the tires.
Oh wait I hear him.
Somewhere?
Oh gosh I thought I saw him.
Where the hell is he?
You know what let's just...
He sounds behind.
Guys am I blind?
Am I blind?
I don't know.
I don't even know where I need to be going.
I don't remember this area.
I'll...
Oh!
Oh I think...
This... Is it up there?
I guess I could like go around the area and kind of...
Sorry for your eyes.
I'm so sorry.
So sorry... Oh my gosh.
Why'd he have to go?
Heck!
I think there's two of them though.
I hear another one.
My sensitive ears.
I hear someone up there.
The sonar in this game...
I don't know.
I don't like it very much.
Can I climb up that?
No.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Turn around Snake.
Where'd he go?
Oh there's his ass.
Get his ass.
I mean shoot but like...
Get him.
Oh my gosh.
He's like looking right at me.
Is there anyone else?
I hear a buzzing.
I hear some bees I think.
Go up Snake.
Hide in this little cubby.
Turn around.
There we go.
Nice.
Anybody else?
We're so stealthy you guys.
I'm literally a snake right now.
I'm an actual snake.
Either the sonar is useless...
Or...
We're good for now.
Hmm.
Answer
me.
He's my kid.
No!
You suck!
Oh my gosh.
I didn't even see it.
You suck!
We're so blocked.
You suck man.
Good job sir.
Thank you so much for the 50.
Thank you.
Oh wow.
That was so silly!
That was
so silly!
Oh, I think
it's a frog, whatever's in there.
Alright, let's climb up this tree maybe.
Maybe if I climb up the tree...
I can get a vantage point, right?
And not... Oh, I see it now!
Come on, it's so rude.
We were ready for the end, but not the pit.
It's so rude.
Alright, I'm gonna have to turn my thermals back on.
I'm sorry, everybody.
Actually, can I even get... Oh, here.
He's right there.
Yeah, that's right.
And, uh...
The other guy is...
I don't think I can see him from here.
Anybody?
No, I didn't kill him!
What do you think I am?
I'm no monster.
My river's gonna be so clean.
Okay.
Alright.
Easy.
Oh, nope.
Grab ya.
Missed the start of the stream.
Sorry to keep you waiting.
Well, welcome in.
Welcome in.
What was it?
Oh, sonar.
Oh, I forgot to press L3.
I also...
Don't think I understand how it works.
Hmm.
Anyway...
Thermal Goggles is pretty good.
I don't hear anybody, so...
Sorry, I'm a little slow today.
Like I said, I'm feeling a little tired and under the weather and everything.
Oh, there he is.
Oh my god, wait.
I don't want that on.
No.
Thank you.
Where is he?
Wait, where?
Thank ya!
Is it just these two guys?
Tempest!
Thanks for the vibe, Grifton!
Thank you so much!
Is there anything else in this area?
Besides, like...
Anything else?
I think it's...
Yeah, it's this way.
First time... Dono here wanted to tell you I saw your last MGS3 stream.
And remember, I hadn't played Metal Gear before.
But it was...
I bought the whole series and now I'm on MGS2.
Professor!
Oh my gosh, thank you!
It says it's your first time, Dono, but then it says it's your first Super Chat.
I mean, your third.
Which is it?
But yes.
Metal Gear... MGS2 is...
So good.
So, so good.
I guess we're good.
Look at my... Wait, what's that?
Oh, Mushroom.
Oh, first time donating to me.
Oh, I thought it always meant like...
Like that's your first or your third ever... like on the channel.
I didn't realize it was ever.
Sorry, I didn't mean to doubt you.
I was just confused.
Why can't I get the Mushroom?
Yeah, have fun with it.
Why can't I get it?
I give up.
Gosh, it scared me.
Mushroom.
Grabbable Mushroom.
Never mind.
Wait.
Stop getting up, Snake.
I want to get that.
There we go.
We need snacks.
Oh my gosh, that guy right there scared the heck out of me.
I think I got him.
There we go.
Oh no.
What do you mean, what's wrong?
Who else is there?
Is that a person?
Wait.
Oh!
Shoot.
What's wrong?
There we go.
We're fine, everybody.
We're fine.
Don't worry about it.
Everything's good.
Everything is a-okay.
What's wrong?
Nothing's wrong.
Don't worry about it.
Gosh.
Why do you keep asking me those questions?
What's wrong?
Nothing's wrong.
Right, guys?
Everything's okay?
We're okay.
Checking the area.
I don't think there's anybody else around here.
What's wrong?
Nothing.
Did
you guys see that?
Oh my gosh.
Yo.
I'm not even gonna go touch them.
They're not-they're not worth it.
They're not worth it.
I'm too scared.
Okay.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry for your eyes, everybody.
Okay.
Wait.
East?
We gotta go north.
Okay.
Oh.
The heat vision doesn't bother me at all.
I'm glad.
Cause I'm gonna keep using it.
Climb.
Let's get our little vantage point.
Uh.
Oh.
It's tall.
Any?
Two.
Wait.
I should probably change.
I'm just a leaf.
Oh.
Hmm.
Will they still see me?
Where'd they go anyway?
I hear-oh.
There's one.
And then the guy's gonna go, what's wrong?
Oh shit.
Ummm...
What do you mean?
What?
No!
It was a...
It was a fly!
What are you talking about?
Attack!
Oh shit.
Are they gonna notice me or anything?
What do you mean attacked?
Don't be dramatic.
Oh shit.
Snake, you need to go.
Snake, you need to leave.
Snake, it's time to go.
Oh shit.
Snake?
Go, go, go.
Just run.
Please respond.
What if I ran up a tree?
Oh my god, there's a house.
Oh, I remember this place.
You don't even see me.
Don't even see me.
Oh, they do.
They definitely see me.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Take him down.
Guy number one.
Guy number two.
There we go.
Come here, you.
Over there.
Come here.
Everybody!
Stay calm, okay?
CQC is good stuff.
And I'm just gonna...
Beep.
Oh, where's my Trank?
I mean, not my Trank, my Suppressor.
He's fine now.
They heard, but...
I mean, they already knew I was here.
Look,
they're so dumb.
No way this works.
All I did was stand behind a tree.
All I have is a cut!
We're totally fine!
Thanks for making my birthday some memorable last night off.
Even though you hate us, I still...
Wait, Paige!
I saw you.
Do you like my wink?
Let's see...
Do I need to get the...
No, I just have a cut, right?
So we probably just need...
A little disinfectant...
A little like...
A little bandage...
What else do I need?
Oh, a deep cut!
Suit circuit...
Cut.
Oh, shoot.
No, no, no, no.
They lost the enemy, you guys.
Winner, winner.
Chicken dinner.
What's wrong?
Winner, winner.
Chicken dinner, baby.
What's wrong?
This guy is...
Oh, he's keeping rations on.
Okay, let's...
I'm gonna survey the area real quick.
Okay, we're good.
Wow, you got a nice little shack here.
What's wrong?
Shadow time!
More bullets.
I'll take everything you got.
What else is in here?
We're winning, guys.
We're winning.
What is this?
Okay.
Where's the...
Where are we going?
Oh, I need to go back around, don't I?
Shoot.
What is this?
Can you...
There we go.
There's nothing under the house, right?
Oh, there's something over here, too.
Wait, is this a little...
Armory or something?
I should blow this up, huh?
Wait, can I?
Oh, there's the door.
Sorry.
Oh, they're gonna be so hungry!
They're all asleep, so...
It should be okay if I blow it up.
Watching for traps.
It's this way, right?
Check the boxes in the cabin.
There was a gun in the cabin.
Oh, what?
No way!
Oh.
No!
I have to go all the way back.
I have to hope nobody wakes up.
Maybe I should put some guys back to sleep.
Oh, wait.
They're still on three Z's.
Never mind.
The boxes?
What boxes?
Oh, sorry.
These boxes?
Like these?
Other room.
What?
Guys, there's like five rooms.
These boxes?
Guys, there's so many rooms.
What are you... Oh, I'm hungry.
What are you...
Tasted terrible.
Oh, no.
I think the broken floor just goes underneath... Oh, this room.
Oh, I see!
M63!
A machine gun.
Let's go.
Anything under here?
How do I get out of here?
You guys, I don't even know who's saying what's wrong.
I don't even know where they are.
Oh, shoot.
There?
Oh, ah!
I saw somebody running.
Huh?
Um...
Okay.
Those two guys are still down.
There's a ghost roaming the forest.
Crawl to safety!
Oh, wait.
Oh, there he is.
There is a
person.
He's like running, running.
Are you okay?
What's wrong?
Oh, no.
Now I'm doing it.
Why are you running?
Oh, my God.
Guys, they're everywhere.
You guys, we gotta get out of here.
Oh, no!
Guys, we gotta get out of here.
You guys!
Okay, I'm just gonna run for it.
Oh, my God.
When does that map end?
Here we go.
Yeah!
We made it!
What's wrong?
My TNT.
I blew it up.
Don't worry.
Uh-oh.
He's hungry.
Wait a second.
This is where we came...
Oh, gosh.
Which way is north?
I see.
I'm famished.
Maybe I should throw a snake.
Where is he, though?
Oh, my gosh.
Complaining over here.
Shut up.
I wonder if I can just crawl over there.
Can I go this way?
I hear somebody walking.
I'm scared.
Who was that?
No!
I hit you!
Nothing?
Shit.
Nothing's going on.
Nothing is going on.
Chill out.
God.
Yeah.
That's right.
Okay.
Sheesh.
He, like, dodged it.
For real.
Right?
There's no way I could have missed that.
There's no way.
I should have missed that.
This poor guy over here is so hungry.
Okay.
So...
It's, like, right here.
Oh.
Yes.
It's right here.
But avoid the trap.
And avoid any other traps.
And go north.
South?
If up on map, why south?
No.
Oh.
Snake.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
I almost didn't see him.
He's so camouflaged.
Hey, B.O.
Hello?
No!
So if I can hold him up...
Don't I get, uh... something special?
Won't he wiggle something out of him?
I beg of you.
Grant me the strength to take this
You have to do it three times.
Guys, I can barely hold up a single man.
I don't know.
I'd like to keep sleeping.
You have my thanks.
You can get his gun if you try and kill him.
I have to thank you for waking me.
I guess I don't have to use my...
I don't like to waste the bullets, but I don't have to use my suppressor.
...would have been eternal.
If you hadn't shown up in a week...
Do you hear me, Snake?
I am the end.
I am here to send you to your ultimate fate.
You'll make a fine quarry for my final hunt.
Nooo!
Cinema rule!
Wait...
I can't wait for the cutscene end.
I got it all over my hands.
Because I was rushing.
I picked it up to drink and I was rushing to press the R1.
Nooo!
Cinema rule!
Eva, I found that sniper we were talking about.
That's the end.
He's a legend.
Known as the father of sniping.
I've got experience sniping in urban and marine environments.
I'm gonna go throw it in the sink.
What about the forest?
Never.
I see.
Well, that forest is divided into three areas.
I have to move, like, all my stuff off of the...
A river, a plateau, and a clearing.
He should be lying in wait for you in one of those places.
Sounds like this may take a while.
It'll be a test of endurance.
Be careful, though.
From what I've heard, the end has an almost supernatural knack for camouflaging himself.
So, whoever moves first loses.
This guy's over a hundred years old, though, so I should have the advantage in terms of stamina.
I wouldn't be so sure if I were you.
Why's that?
I've heard that his body is photosynthetic, like a plant.
What is he, some kind of monster?
Sorry, guys, sorry.
On top of that, he can speak to the forest, too.
So, in other words, he knows it inside out.
Uh-huh.
But he doesn't know you.
I'm sure you can beat him.
Don't worry.
I intend to.
Wait.
Oh, gosh, it's all over my controller, too.
No, no, no, no.
Where did I throw the paper towel?
Okay.
Sorry, I have to go throw my desk mat into a sink so it doesn't stain.
BRB.
I think I cleaned off everything.
Sorry.
For those...
I spilled my coffee.
I spilled my coffee all over the place.
And I had to go throw my desk mat in.
In the sink.
So that it wouldn't stain.
No.
I really like my desk mat.
I hope it's okay.
I'll let it soak.
And then after the stream, I'll put it in the washing machine.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
That really threw me out.
Okay.
I'm okay.
Oh, okay.
We're...
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, okay.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Let's see.
What's...
I didn't get the tranq sniper.
So, I guess...
Okay.
I'm not going to...
But I don't need a sniper sniper gun.
Oh.
Oh, gosh.
Technically, you can sneak up on the end once.
All you need is to aim his gun at him three times after sneaking up and grab the item before boss battle is over.
Oh.
Okay.
I'm gonna call people to kind of...
Snake, the end is a veteran sniper.
Ugh.
He's hiding somewhere in those woods waiting for you to appear.
If he sees you, he'll shoot without hesitation.
Make your way through the forest, hiding along the way, and watch out for signs of the end.
Anticipate his movements and come up on his side or get behind him for a chance to attack.
Be careful.
The end uses a special kind of tranquilizer round.
If he shoots you with one of those tranquilizer rounds, you'll start to lose stamina fast.
When your stamina gauge reaches zero, you're dead.
You'll pass out.
Oh no.
If you're hit by a tranquilizer round, go into the survival viewer right away and treat the wound.
Okay.
Use your knife to dig out the needle.
Eww.
If you run out of stamina, it's all over.
Make sure you keep your stamina up by hunting for food on a regular basis.
Okay.
This battle will be a long, grueling sniper duel.
But don't let your guard down, not even for a single moment.
Okay.
Um...
Either way, you can do it.
You got anything?
I know it's hard to believe, but the end is apparently capable of photosynthesis.
That's crazy.
He's probably got an edge over you in terms of stamina.
You should start hunting for plants and animals and prepare for a battle of attrition.
Okay.
Um...
I know that, like...
It's...
Oh gosh.
You, like, look for his, um, his little glint and then you...
I can't remember exactly how to find him in an area.
But you, like, look for the gleam of his sniper.
I want to photosynthesize, too.
You just do it.
Socroviano Forest is a big place.
There's times like this that the map function and the survival viewer can be your best friend.
Not only does it show you the terrain and the places you've been...
Yeah, if you wait a week to find him...
But you can also use it to figure out...
You can also use it to figure out which locations the end has chosen for his sniping position.
But I'm not gonna do that because that's so boring.
Learn the terrain and try to catch the end off guard from behind.
Shut up.
Everybody's saying...
Just change the clock on your PS2.
No!
That's so boring!
What are you talking about?
This is, like, such a cool fight.
You wanna just skip it?
It's funny, though.
No!
Oh, I see him.
I see him.
How can I...
Oh, wait.
How would I get around him from there?
Hmm.
He is... up there.
On the...
He is...
He is up there.
Up there.
Uh...
Slowly.
How do I even get up there?
I don't know.
Uh-uh.
Uh-uh-uh.
Can we take a two-week break from MGS3 to beat the end?
Oh, whoops.
Snake.
Turn this way.
There we go.
I don't want him to just see me and shoot me and all.
So I'll have to...
I think my camouflage is okay, but...
Yeah.
Oh, here we go.
Nice.
Okay.
Let's go.
Crawling.
All the way there to his spot, his vantage point.
Crawling in the grass.
My wounds will heal and cure.
Hmm.
Oh, okay.
Also, doesn't... wait, but doesn't the end heal in...
Oh gosh, you guys...
Doesn't the end heal...
in the sun?
Let's eat this European rabbit.
Oh!
Not too bad, alright.
Maybe it will be more hassle than...
that it's worth.
What the heck was that?
What the...
A trap?
Stupid trap.
Couldn't even reach me.
I'm too small.
Some crazy noises going on.
Wait, okay, hold on.
We're trying to get...
I'm... oh!
How did I... wait, okay, yeah, cause...
Okay.
Where the heck is he now?
I think I gotta...
I'm completely... lost.
Come here, bunny.
You're not too bad.
You're not too shabby with a snack.
I'll take it.
Oh my goodness.
Trying to find this guy.
Okay, so he is... up there, maybe?
Okay, I just gotta keep going for... okay.
I don't think I need to... crawl, but probably for the best so he doesn't hear me.
Can I get up here?
Um...
No.
Guys, did I mess up?
I guess we'll just keep going.
For now, I'll collect food.
No.
Anything we come across.
Um...
Okay.
Wanted to make sure there were no traps in there, you know?
Oh, just kidding.
My food... well, I can eat.
I can eat.
I still have room.
Let's have a...
let's have a...
a...
euroluminescent mushroom.
Or...
No.
The ink...
Oh, it tasted bad.
Sorry, Snake.
Sick.
Okay.
Ta ta ta ta...
Ta ta ta ta ta ta...
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta...
ta ta ta ta ta ta...
Da -da-da-da-da-da-da, da-da-da-da-da-da-da, ba-ba-da-ba-da-ba-da-ba.
Where are we?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Keep on crawling, Snake.
Keep on crawling.
This is a test of endurance.
A test of...
He didn't notice that, right?
A test of stealth and stuff.
I hope he fell asleep.
Grandpa, fall asleep.
Grandpa, go to bed.
Alright.
Watch your eyes!
What is that?
He...
Guys, I think I don't remember where he is.
Snake, you gotta be like a little more quiet when you do that, you know?
Okay, I give up.
Zero has more advice.
Let's listen.
Zero!
The binoculars and first person view will prove useful in detecting the enemy's presence.
You should also be making use of your motion detector, active sonar...
But he's not moving!
...and anti-personnel sensor.
You might also try using the directional microphone.
Oh, that's right!
The Mic D!
Mic D.
Let's hear it.
Let's see if we hear his little honk meemees.
Oh, I was like, I don't have it.
It's in my backpack.
I don't usually use this, but...
I guess I'll... Oh, my bad.
My bad.
Well, we'll get rid of the box for now.
Which seems like a sin, but...
Wait, where is my mic?
Do I not have it?
Oh, mic is a weapon.
Oh, just kidding.
Well, we gotta add that anyway.
Mic, mic, mic, mic, mic, mic, mic...
Directional mic!
Oh.
I think I got rid of it on accident.
No, no, no.
I got rid of it on accident.
Where is it?
There, there.
Okay.
Okay!
There, there, there, there, there.
Good morning, Minso.
My sighs are on fire from four hours of otage.
I hope you and the other performers enjoyed your shenanigans in the back.
Oh, enjoyed our shenanigans.
You did so good.
Thank you!
He's talking to himself.
So is he.
Oh, I see him!
Oh, I see him, I see him, I see him, I see him, I see him.
Shoot, how am I supposed to get around him?
Like, to behind him?
I did a big old circle, and in the end...
It didn't even matter.
Oh, but this says this is the sniping point.
Uh...
This is the end.
Where did his... where did the gleam go?
Oh my gosh, it's raining.
Where'd he go?
I might...
I need, like, ten hour ambiance of this, you know?
The other way.
What are you talking...
No.
He was over there, was he not?
You can use thermal goggles and binoculars at the same time?
How?
That's him though, isn't it?
No, that's a mushroom.
Where the heck...?
Oh wait, if I use the mic am I even...
...not gonna be able to hear him, am I?
What!?
He's literally asleep!
Now's our chance.
We can see him because he's asleep!
Nice.
I know I'm taking a pretty long approach to this but...
Oh my god it's a cliff and it ends and how do I get up there?
How the hell?
Oh my god.
He's like right there.
He's right there!
Whoops, my bad.
I wanted to use the scope.
BionicHippo, thank you for the five gifted!
Thank you!
I want to hold him up.
I do really want to try.
I...
I'll be honest...
If Apache is listening, sorry.
I haven't really watched so many speedruns of this game.
So I wonder... I'm so curious what the speedrun strat is...
...for the end.
I don't want him to wake up.
How do I get up there you guys?
How do I get up there?
Ahhhh!
Hmm.
Taking him out early?
Probably, right?
Maybe...
Oh, maybe I have to...
...go through like one of the other areas.
Oh gosh.
You get him in one go?
That's crazy.
I've only watched speedrun stuff of MGS2 and MGS1.
Oh, oh!
Oh my gosh.
Honk!
Me-me-me-me-me-me.
Me-me-me-me-me-me-me.
Oh my gosh.
I want to just keep crawling because I'm afraid if I wake him up on accident he will leave...
you know.
Honk!
Me-me-me-me-me-me.
Just keep...
Just keep sleeping my man.
Keep sleeping my man.
Why not three onwards?
I just never got around to it.
That's it.
Plain and simple.
Whenever I watch people play, there's like a YouTube channel that has 24 hour Metal Gear game play up and I have that on, essentially.
I don't... I don't... Yeah, he's up there.
He's up there.
Oh, it's dusty.
It's dusty, dusty.
This here, right?
I'm just changing my brain chemistry.
Same.
Or is this just a room?
I can't remember.
Oh, it's just a room.
Oh, he's a heavy sleeper.
He's a heavy sleeper.
Where's the... Where's the... Oh my gosh, the snake.
Go forward.
Yeah, grandpa's taking a nap and we're like really trying not to wake him up, you know?
It's very important.
Get him done.
The ambiance is real.
No, it's not a cat.
It's a frog.
Okay, so wait.
What area am I in right now?
I need to go back to south.
Or at the west.
Since we know he's not here...
If I do this...
Where the hell are we?
Do I have to go all the way around?
Hmm.
Oh, hello.
There we go.
Oh my god, grandpa!
No!
You...
Oh, I keep pressing R2... R1 for some reason.
Oh, knife.
Grandpa, please.
You weren't supposed to wake up.
Why would you wake up?
I guess he heard my...
I'm behind a tree though.
Oh my god!
You are not in the same spot at all!
What?
What happened?
Oh my gosh.
My damn throat.
Is he still up there?
Awww!
No!
Ahh!
Gosh, I wonder how Delta will approach the end boss fight.
Probably similar, right?
Ten hour ambiance with intermittent screaming from mint freaky Gavro and these...
And another...
Oh, man.
I think he ran away, didn't he?
Gosh, dang it.
Let me up!
Swim snake!
Grandpa...
Grandpa, I can kill you literally in two seconds.
All it takes is to change my PS2 clock.
Don't mess with me.
Don't mess with me, Grandpa.
You wanna play this game?
Huh?
Grandpa!
I'm trying to play this fair and square with you!
Where did he go?
Where did he shoot from?
Where did he come from?
Where did he go?
And I, Joe.
Oh, I see him.
Wow, he got me in the head!
Wow, Snake survived that.
Or not survived, but like...
He didn't go down.
Why are you still trying to shoot him?
He didn't come down at me!
Stop it!
How..
where are you?
Oh!
It literally is just like, hey, this is where he is at.
Laugh This is like where he is at.
I don't know if we can run out of bullets.
Oh!
Where'd he go?
Wait, what?
I heard him.
I heard his footsteps.
Wait, was that him?
That's him!
Can I follow him?
Okay, I get it.
I get it.
I don't want him to hear my stomach.
Okay, I get it.
I get it.
Eat the rabbit.
I'm gonna... Sorry guys for your eyes.
Oh, his footsteps are gone.
Where did he go?
He's so fast for an old man who's literally on his death bed.
Oh, I think he went to the next area.
That's probably why.
I think he...
went to another area.
Yeah, my camel.
What the hell is that?
What is that?
Is that a pig?
Oh, it's a goat!
It's a goat, you guys!
Okay.
Camel.
Leaf.
It's the goat.
Or maybe he didn't leave the area.
Maybe I just lost him because I'm slow.
No!
Oh my goodness.
Did I lose him because I'm slow?
No!
No, no, no!
I know.
Crouch walking?
I wish was in this game.
No, I don't see his footsteps.
I don't see footsteps.
I missed him.
I don't...
see that's a bird.
Yeah, I guess let's try the mic, huh?
Oh, wait.
Damn mic.
Wait.
Did I hear him?
Damn mic.
Thought I heard him breathing.
Rock, what is your wisdom?
Hey.
Wait.
I think I hear him breathing.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, it hurts my eyes.
He's this way.
And while we're at it, we can grab ourselves a little snack.
Plenty of time.
Oh.
Nice.
Why in the middle?
He is breathing.
But where?
Holy cow, guys.
This is gonna take forever.
Daniel, thank you!
I know I'm a little late on this.
This is my happy birthday to my favorite green ghost made silly little lady.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Oh he's close.
Oh he's close close.
I think this might be where he's at.
Hold on.
That's a bird.
Where did he go?
Wow.
We heard him so well.
We heard him so clearly.
Map?
It's like one of these...
Oh that's not a bird.
That's mushrooms.
He woke up.
He's rising.
He's right there.
He's right there you guys.
Oh my gosh.
Oh he was looking my way.
Oh my god he almost saw me.
Oh he almost saw me.
He almost saw me.
I was too fast.
He heard my crawling.
Can I sneak crawl with the d-pad even?
Hmm.
Guys I'm nervous.
How do I hold him up?
How do I hold up?
I just walk up and then I...
I hold him up and then...
What do I do?
I'm scared!
No MGS4 worm.
Let me check my camel.
See if there's...
I don't think there's anything better than this but...
Oh my god.
This is the end.
Yeah keep talking to yourself grandpa.
Oh gosh.
This is the end.
Point gun at head, then away, then head, then away until he drops the camel.
Okay.
He won't leave though right?
I'm so scared I'm gonna mess this up.
I'm so scared!
I'm so bad at holding guys up.
You know.
I'm so bad at it you guys.
Oh my god we're like right here.
Oh gosh!
Look even he's getting tired.
Okay.
This is the end.
Maybe he'll fall asleep again.
Don't worry you won't screw it up.
NX you have so much faith in me.
Thank you.
PC version not have analog.
I'm on my PS2.
I'm playing subsistence.
N's breathing got me sleepy.
If he didn't keep saying this is the end.
Like his breathing and the ambiance would be...
Like especially the water in the background.
It'd be a really great like 10 hour loop.
I'm even afraid to equip my gun.
I feel like he's gonna hear it.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
The rustling of the leaves.
He's gonna be like that's not a bug.
I know that rustling.
That's a man's rustling.
Oh my god.
Don't touch the grass.
I'm trying not to.
Oh my god.
That's a man's rustling.
I know I'm...
Sorry guys.
I know I'm being like so stupid here.
I'm just so scared.
I'm so scared.
Okay.
I wish he'd fall asleep.
The rain.
Yes.
Okay.
Oh my god.
This is the end.
Okay.
Did you know that this is the end?
I know.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Sorry guys.
I'm so jumpy.
I'm so...
Freeze.
Where did you...
Yeah.
That's right.
Freeze.
I don't think so.
What the...
No.
One.
Give it up.
Gotta put the gun away.
Freeze.
Where'd he go?
There he is.
Just run after him.
It's okay, guys.
We got him.
Just gotta keep running after him.
I just gotta keep going after him.
I don't see anything else but him.
Okay, guys.
Wait, uh, oh, there they are.
I was like, where did his footsteps go?
Oh my god, he's so fast!
I think we lost him.
Historical one-man- did I actually get one-manned?
Wait, oh, this way.
Guys, we're still on his trail.
Oh, sorry.
Uh, but actually I do- oh, no, no, no.
Okay.
Uniform.
Aha!
Yeah!
Come on.
Sh-shimmy!
Shimmy!
Yippee!
Oh.
Hahaha!
Just keep shooting at him while he's running.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I just realized my, uh, suppressor.
Oh.
Run, Grandpa!
Come on, Grandpa!
He's so fast!
How is he such a fast grandpa?
I don't understand.
Who's calling me?
Shut up!
Oh, my God!
Wait.
How?
The hell?
Where the hell?
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God.
Snake looks so cool with his- with the- with the- he looks like Splinter Cell real.
Ouch!
Phew!
Let's eat something real quick.
We'll eat an instant noodle.
That's damn good.
Um... ghost abuses Elder, tries to get him to join the wisdom survey.
Put on the moss camo... ooh, true!
True!
True, true, true.
We're gonna be so... no one is gonna... Holy plus 30!
You guys, this is the first time I've ever had the moss camo!
I'm so excited!
Yeah, I'm so excited.
Thank you.
Twinning!
Oh!
Ah!
Gosh.
Somehow I got him again.
Oops, how did I miss?
Oh!
Oh.
Oh, shoot!
No!
Where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
He's so fast!
Oh!
I didn't crawl slow.
Sorry, I forgot to do the... I forgot to do the slow crawl.
I forgot to do the slow crawl, my bad.
This is as close as we're getting to OctoCamo.
Let's go, baby!
Oh my god!
Hey mister, I see you running through there.
Come here.
You can... You can run!
And you can hide!
Boy, snake's coming for you.
Oh, shit!
Wait, where did he go?
Oh my god!
OH!
Hold
it!
Freeze.
Oh, shoot!
He's not runnin', though is he?
Uh... Oh, oh god.
Ahhhh?
Yes he is!
Oh!
Oh, man!
Is this maybe the most chaotic end fight ever?
Ha ha ha!
This is maybe so chaotic, and so crazy!
Ha Gra.
This is like a Betty Hill skit.
For real!
Does the end have to deal with loading times, I wonder?
Oh my god, Snake, are you okay?
Ow!
Shoot.
Whoops, uh, backpack.
No, sorry, food.
What's wrong with me?
I will have a little bit of a crab.
I almost said frog.
Pretty tasty!
And then... oh my gosh, right in the cheek.
In the cheek!
Oh my gosh, Snake.
How are you still awake?
Crazy.
A little... yeah, give me a little kiss on the cheek.
How cute!
I wanted the end to be slow, methodical sniper battle of wits meant...
Ah!
Kirby redialed, man!
Oh, gosh.
Wait, there he is!
Does he still see me?
Yes.
Uh, yeah, he saw me.
Oh my god.
No!
Ah!
Na, na, na, na, na, na, na!
Come here!
Old man!
He's like, god, you call yourself a son of the boss?
She's so smart!
What's wrong with you?
You're a crazy person!
Come here, old man!
I won't, I won't stop until you're dead in the ground!
Come on!
Old man!
Where are you?
This way?
Can I see him?
We see him.
We know where he is.
Right there.
Oh my god!
I'm at 100% camo!
How do I slow crawl through...
...through the grass, though?
Oh my god, it's a bird.
Oh, he saw the bird, not me.
Oh my god, he heard the bird!
Of course he didn't want to fight the last weeks.
Yeah, I know, it's so silly.
Which way is he facing?
Okay.
How is this guy not out of stamina?
I've chased him everywhere by now, you know?
I've chased him all over.
Like, this guy's gotta be out of stamina.
If I go in the grass, will he hear me?
I'm concerned about that.
Oh...
This is the end.
The sun's gonna heal him, I know, I know.
Yippee!
Ah, yeah!
We got him, baby!
Only took, like, an hour.
This is the end.
Hold your breath and count to ten.
Spirits of the forest...
...I thank you.
The boss... would be proud of you.
The time has come for a younger generation to rise.
Squeak!
Squeak, squawk!
I've been wandering for more than a century...
...and now my journey... comes to a close.
What a splendid way...
No!
Bird, get away!
He's gonna explode!
Bird!
Grandpa!
I have no regrets.
I can return to the forum of love.
He doesn't even say that.
It's kind of crazy.
Oh, his dentures!
I hope that's collectible.
And... yeah.
Dramatic dentures.
Good job, everybody.
Good job.
We really Benny-hilled our way out of that, didn't we?
And...
The forests open up for us.
Ahem.
Where is his gun?
Do you want to say it?
Yes, please.
I would.
Thank you, thank you.
Chuu!
Thank you!
Not only you got his gun and camo...
You also have one of the most entertaining end fights I've ever seen.
So happy for that.
Snake, have you ever seen Jason and the Argonauts?
I can't say I have.
It's based on Greek mythology.
Snake, have you watched anything in your life?
There's this ship called the Argo.
And it sets sail in search of the Golden Fleece.
Along the way, it encounters many dangers.
I've actually never heard of this one before.
Live death, spontaneous combustion.
Like bronze giants and the deadly seven-headed Hydra.
And the vicious bird-like harpies.
The most spectacular part of all was the battle scene...
with an army of skeletons.
Oh wait, maybe I do know this.
I just didn't know the...
It was like they were actually standing up and fighting.
I didn't know the name of it.
Are you serious?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If you don't believe me, go see it for yourself.
Then you'll want to see the magical movies.
I know the skeletons.
It's like classic.
It was totally amazing.
Yeah.
Yeah, all right.
If I make it back alive, I'll go see it.
Yeah, I do remember this.
It just came out.
So I'm sure it'll still be playing.
So funny.
It just came out.
All right.
Where is the gun at?
I feel like we're going to be using this camo for like the whole game.
Sorry, snake.
I know you hate these.
It's on the ledge.
I was staring at it?
It was over here?
Did I miss it?
I stare at a lot of things.
I look in a bunch of directions.
This way?
Over here?
If I use the thermal goggles...
It's a gun, though.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Oh, yeah.
And let's get a little snack on the way out.
Oh.
Come here.
Crazy that these bunnies aren't afraid of us.
Guys, I'm going to have so much serum.
It's awesome.
You guys, the bunnies?
I have to get the bunnies.
They taste delicious.
I'm looking around for anything else.
I didn't realize this until someone pointed it out, but they really did change the portrait angles for Paramedic in the future re-releases.
Did they?
A Diploko.
A Momloko.
Got to get my Boblokos on.
R-fruit.
Wait, do I have this?
Oh.
Yes!
The Boblokos and Mokos.
I don't think those were very tasty either, but it's fine.
Oh, another snack.
Sorry, guys.
We got to fill up.
I ate some of my good stuff, so we got to get other good things.
Come here.
No, my food is full.
Let's eat some...
Oh.
Not the...
The...
Oh, yeah.
It said...
Oh, wait.
It was said to be tasty.
Let's try it.
Oh.
Never mind.
Everybody...
All my homies hate the Boblokos.
Thank you!
How many more rabbits must be murdered in cold blood and let rot before your vengeful spirit is satisfied...
Oh.
I'm sorry.
We're going the right way, right?
We got something here.
I gotta go north.
Before that though, guys, I gotta go to the bathroom real quick.
Here, I'll leave you with a good show.
I must go to...
the little ghost's room.
There you go.
For free?
Hold on, hold on.
Oh wait, you can't even tell because I'm...
You can't tell because I'm green!
The filter!
Me, me looks like...
Okay.
Oh, we gotta go say I'm gone fishing.
I'm gone fishing.
I tanned.
Oh my gosh.
I'm tanned.
Okay.
Barely.
I'm back, I'm back, I'm back, I'm back, I'm back.
Sorry about that.
Okie dokie.
Sorry about that!
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Did you wash your hands?
What do you mean?
This time I wash my hands every time!
What are you talking about, this time?
I always wash my hands.
I'm not some...
moss.
I'm not a... I'm...
animal.
I'm no animal.
Oh, I forgot I was in.
Oh my gosh.
Old control mode.
Okay.
Onwards?
Wait...
Onwards.
I think.
This way.
Oh.
Dang it.
I gotta go north.
Wait.
This says north, but I went north last time and I went south.
Oh, I see the X.
The X marks the spot.
There's no traps around here, are there?
I didn't even think about that.
I just kept going.
Grab some...
Oh, splint!
Very good.
We like those.
What a good place to recharge, right?
Call Sigint with the end's rifle?
Oh yeah!
I've never heard...
Oh wait, I didn't...
Man, I didn't even need that sniper.
I'm too good.
I'm too good at this game.
Backup pack.
Get rid of you and equip you.
Oh my gosh.
The Mosin Nagant.
Nice.
I'm just too good.
You can tell me to shut up now.
You can be like...
Shut the hell up.
Nugget.
Snake, what's that you're wearing?
It's moss camouflage.
I got it from the end.
Interesting.
It seems to have part of the end's power sealed within it.
If you wear it in a place where the sun shines, you'll automatically recover stamina.
I forgot about that!
It'll also give you a high rate of camouflage in Siviatogorni and Sokrovieno.
The end's home territory.
I forgot about that.
Woah!
So, you're wearing woodland face paint.
Boktai real, yeah.
The woodland paint is most effective in forest environments.
Maybe I need to equip the gun.
It'll work best if you use it when infiltrating forest areas.
I completely forgot!
I am on some photosynthesis now!
What's the times three mean?
That scares me a little bit.
Oh, it's the skuild!
Nagant?
Yeah, It's what the End was using.
I see...
The M1891-30 Mozen Nagan is a real beauty of a bolt action sniper rifle.
Nagant?
It's been in use since WW2.
Mozen Nagants are created by selecting the best made weapons out of the regular M1891-30 rifle production line for their high precision, and upgrading them to sniper rifles.
Hmm, I'll go to war.
Wow.
Ooh!
I bought one because of this game?
Awesome.
One shot.
One kill.
The aim button.
I tried it, but I...
Okay.
Call in with the animal camel.
Yeah.
Wait, aim... but how do I go into first person view?
Oh, like I am in first person, but like shouldn't I have...
Shouldn't I be able to look through the scope?
Oh, L1.
Thank you.
Awesome.
You only have one shot?
Actually, I have 26.
One shot.
One kill.
Yeah, you can... it does say you can zoom in.
Oh, there we go.
Times 10.
Oh, guys.
These guys are never gonna know what's hidden.
Oh, let's do that.
Oop, camel.
I don't think I called him with the animal.
If I kissed you right now, I bet you'd taste like a wild beast.
Pattern clothing, face paint, tactical movements.
These are the elements of camouflage that will allow you to deceive your enemy.
To camouflage yourself, first press the start button to check out the survival view.
Oh, he's just telling me basic stuff.
Then select camouflage, and you'll see two more options.
He's like, you're not camouflage, you're in leopard print.
You're being fancy.
You can change your uniform to change your field uniform.
Simple, really.
Make sure and choose something that'll match your surroundings.
Rawr, rawr.
Oh, that reminds me.
Do you guys remember Awa Awa Dog?
Awa Awa.
Forgot what that dog's name was called.
Let me try one more time.
Covering your body is a good start.
Okay, never mind.
Sorry, Sagan.
Maybe we already got the am...
am...
animal...
camouflage...
talk already.
I don't remember.
I can't believe it's plus five more than the moss.
How the hell?
Maybe because...
Wait, I never got to eat the goat.
Wait, guys.
I never got to eat the goat.
I got it.
It's part of my buffet.
Should we go find one?
So if I stand here...
Wait.
If I stand here...
my stamina will increase.
I'm waiting.
We got to eat a goat.
We got to first find a goat.
Oh, wait.
There's sunlight over here.
Oh my gosh.
It goes up so fast, even.
I had no idea it would be so fast.
Yo, that's amazing!
What does Snake say when he gets the...
When he gets the solar gun in MGS4?
He rises it up.
What does Kojima have with Sun?
He's really... Oh!
There's a goat!
I wish I could Fulton him.
My first instinct was to Fulton the guy.
Oh my god!
Just one hit!
I'm so sorry.
He goes... Right?
Let's throw out these.
They taste bad.
Your streams have been keeping me sane while laid out at home with COVID.
Pneumonia for the past month.
No!
Never fails to raise my spirits.
Thanks for watching!
Share the good vibes.
Oh my gosh!
Feel better soon!
Feel better soon.
I'm so sorry.
That sucks.
I got a goat!
And a rabbit.
I have a friend.
She sends me pictures of her rabbits.
I hope she's not watching this.
They eat their own.
That's right.
I hope she's not watching this.
It's called cecal feces.
Oh.
When the rabbit eats fiber, the fiber is fermented in the rabbit's appendix or cecum and turns into a nutritious substance full of vitamins.
The rabbit excretes the substance and then eats it again to absorb the nutrients.
Wow.
That's a neat trick.
I think I'll give it a try.
Snake.
Rabbits and humans don't work that...
I'm just kidding.
You really thought I was going to eat it?
A little.
Yeah.
Even I wouldn't do that.
I guess not.
But how do those cecal feces taste?
What?
I'm just kidding.
She doesn't understand your humor like I do, snake.
I see you caught a markhor.
A markhor.
The markhor is a kind of wild goat that lives in mountainous areas.
It's quite large, so I don't think you'll be able to capture one alive, even with a tranquilizer gun.
You know what I love watching?
All right.
Speaking of which, do you know the origin of the name markhor?
No.
It means snake eater in Persian.
What?
Snake eater.
Lost your appetite?
Not at all.
So, how does it taste?
I love the way he says that.
It's supposed to be pretty good.
Does it actually...
All right.
Does it actually mean that?
That's crazy.
Does it actually mean snake eater?
If so...
Big...
Huge, if real.
I thought that maybe someone knew a guy named Mark, and he was up to some activities.
And, you know, he owned a lot of goats or something, you know?
You know what's kind of messed up?
They give you this moss, right?
Basically, that you're at the end of the forest.
Do we go back into the forest?
No, we don't.
We go through the mountains, and then we end up at Groznygrad.
Markhor is so beautiful.
The males have huge horns that spiral straight upward.
The folklore is that those horns are two snakes that they ate.
What?
That's so insane.
Insane.
At least I got the photosynthesis.
True, true, true, true, true.
I'm gonna turn it up, you guys.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
First off, let me put my suppressor back on.
I don't use it this much, so I can use it here.
Wacko wacko.
Let me save real quick.
Do you want to save?
Yes ma'am.
I want to have this as its own individual file so that I can always go back to it if I ever want to climb the ladder.
Wacko wacko.
Snake, have you seen Dr. Strangelove or How I Learned to Stop Worrying and Love the Bomb?
I love this movie.
What?
Dr. Strangelove.
Have you seen it?
Oh my god, it's very weird hearing that in this game.
It's about this insane American Air Force commander who sends a bomber out to drop an H-bomb on Russia.
It's a black comedy.
Doesn't sound very funny to me.
The actor who plays Dr. Strangelove also plays two of the other main characters.
That's a good movie.
I've never seen that.
It's actually kind of funny once you get past the scary parts.
It just came out this year, so I bet you could still go and see it.
Maybe when I'm in a lighter state of mind, I'll give it a try.
It's so weird hearing her say Strangelove.
I mean, I know obviously that's where he got the name to, but it's very weird.
It's very weird, right?
Wacko wacko.
Ew.
Okay.
Are you guys ready?
We'll do the old camera angle.
There'll be no one else.
Grime is the way I fly to you.
I'm still in a dream.
Snake Eater.
Bum bum bum bum.
My god.
Oh my god.
We just climbed all the way up that baby.
Dog Strings, thank you so much for the Tony gift.
Thank you.
Every time, every time, every time, every time, every time, every time, every time, every time.
Jump.
Okay!
Snake,
what's wrong?
One more time.
Defeated by the ladder.
Snake, what's wrong?
You can't even climb a ladder properly.
Snake!
Encore, encore.
Which angle do you guys prefer?
I actually prefer this one.
Kind of sad that they changed it.
I guess you can do that.
What a thrill.
I'm searching and I'm melting to you.
Fear in my heart.
But you're so supreme.
I like that they changed the pacing.
I give my life.
Not for honor, but for...
In my time.
There'll be no one else.
Cry the way I fly to you.
I'm still in a dream.
Snake it up.
Again, again, again.
No.
Good stuff.
Good stuff, good stuff.
Good stuff, good stuff, good stuff.
Again.
Oh mosh.
I got to use you for two seconds.
It's pretty nice though.
Now we get to be choco chip.
Yummy.
Wait.
Animals.
We get to be an animal.
These look like...
Like traps over here.
Choco chip.
Alright, once we go down there's no coming back up.
That's it?
Let's see.
Oh yes, there's these birds and stuff.
Is that a snake?
Yeah...
Alright, sorry for your eyes.
Wait, is that a bird or a person?
That's a bird, right?
I can't remember where the people are.
Stay away from me, other snake!
I'm an animal.
I'm an animal right now, I'm an animal.
Where are the people?
90% camouflage is kinda crazy.
It's a bird person.
Wait.
There we go.
Oh, I was like, why is my suppressor not on?
Cause I killed myself.
Wait, where is he?
I see another guy over there too.
What the?
Where did he go?
Mister?
Where did... oh there he is.
He's looking straight at me.
He was looking right at me!
This area freaks me out.
Oh my gosh, this is a scorpion isn't it?
Cause I can't...
It's so lumpy, I can't see where the guys are, you know?
Where are you guy?
Oh, you're still too far.
Oh, there's another guy.
I am an animal, I am an animal.
Yeah, it's lumpy!
What else would you call it?
Oops, sorry.
How else would you say it?
Dang it.
Oh, I'm so close.
Scared off the bird.
I'm gonna put on thermals again.
One, two guys?
That's it, I think.
Two, thank you!
Snack it up!
Can I listen to your version, Minto?
No!
My version is way not good compared to the original.
The original will always reign supreme to me.
Oh my gosh.
Hello?
Hello, aim?
Aim, aim, aim, aim!
What is VTuber playing on PS2?
I'm playing Subsistence on my PS2.
Got him.
Oh my god, there's another guy!
Of course there is.
You can indirectly eat a gu- Oh, true!
Because the birds will like, eat them, right?
And then you eat the bird, and then you eat the guard.
That's kind of sick, isn't it?
That's like the most...
Power of aim assist.
What?
What aim assist?
I'm doing this all on my lonesome.
I wish I had aim assist.
No harm in that.
Oh, shoot.
I hate missing.
I hate missing because it wastes...
Shrank.
It's my birthday today, Andrew!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Andrew.
Happy birthday to...
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday.
Yippee.
Yippee yippee.
Oops.
Hold on.
Let's loot.
I think I need more...
Mark 22.
Bullets, if you have any.
Do you have any tranquilizer bullets?
For me?
That would be great.
Oh.
I have to kill the guards though for them to get eaten, right?
I don't want to do that.
But it is pretty funny to watch them get eaten by birds.
I thought I heard someone walking.
What the?
Wait, there was another guy?
Where?
I'm seeing things.
Who are you talking...
What?
Who?
Where?
Huh?
Right...
Oh my gosh.
I didn't even notice him up there.
I can get him.
Hello?
See?
Easy peasy.
Gosh.
You guys have good eye.
Is there any other secret men?
Awesome.
Now here comes my least favorite part.
We're going into my least favorite part.
I wasn't talking bad about your aim.
I was talking about how bad analog sticks are for aiming.
Oh no, no.
You're all good.
It's both.
My aim is bad.
And also...
Also...
You want to save?
Um...
Also...
The controllers.
Yeah, we go from mountain, which I really don't like this part, into fury.
So, um...
Guys...
I hate this part.
Snake, have you ever seen the guns of Navarone?
Navarone?
Never.
Actually, I don't know this one.
It's about a mission to blow up the huge guns on the island of Navarone during World War II.
Six men are chosen to participate in the operation, each with his own special ability.
They only have until an English destroyer passes by the island to complete their mission.
Facing impossible odds, the six men have to sneak onto the island from a cliff on the southern shore.
That doesn't sound like something I'd want to watch in my free time.
Maybe not for you, but the Major was absolutely crazy about it.
Yeah, because the Major doesn't go onto the front lines.
He told me to tell you how great it was.
Tell him I'll go see it as soon as I get back to the States.
Snake's making a lot of promises.
Do you want to tell him yourself?
No, let's save that for later.
I'd better get back to the mission.
Yeah.
Harrison Ford was in the sequel?
Oh, boy.
You're selling it?
I sense an aura of PTSD when mentioning the fury.
A tad.
Like a little bit.
Oh, yeah!
I blew up the helicopter!
We don't have the helicopter, you guys.
I blew it up.
Oh, shit.
Oh, there's little floaty men, though.
Shoot.
Oh, I hate floaty guys.
Why is there got to be floaty guys?
Scorpion, watch out.
Watch out, Scorpion.
Maybe I can snipe him.
Will they hear it if I snipe him?
I wonder.
Is he coming towards me?
Oh, that's not.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, just your imagination.
Oh, my gosh.
It's hard to use this.
No, he fell asleep.
No, no, he fell asleep.
I promise.
Oh, my gosh.
He fell asleep.
I promise.
I didn't kill him.
He fell asleep and did it himself.
Wait, are they going to come from this way?
Oh, shoot.
Yes, they are.
Funny, funny, funny, funny thing about causing an alert.
They come from everywhere.
I said it's no one, please.
Where's my...
I have the cigar.
Oh, okay, hold on.
Let's see.
Let's unequip...
The D-Mic.
I want the book, too.
We'll just re-equip it another time.
I have my snake, too.
Okay, we have the snake.
Cardboard box time?
No way.
There's no reason for a cardboard box to be here, right?
Why am I in an alert?
I got him.
I killed...
Watch out for this person.
I think they noticed me.
Guys, I think they noticed me.
That's kind of bad.
Um...
I can't shoot floaty men.
I think I should just start over.
I think I should just...
Oh, gosh.
I think maybe I should just start over and then not shoot that guy.
Maybe.
Wait, there's a hole.
Oh, there's a whole alarm.
Oh, my God.
You're kidding me, right?
You're kidding me.
Oh,
my gosh.
How did you...
Maybe I just run.
Time to run for it.
I hear them.
I hear them whirring by me.
Go, snake!
Go!
Just go, snake!
Crawl.
Snake, crawl.
Snake, be like the snake you are and crawl in this hole.
There we go.
I think I'm good.
I think I'm safe.
There's no way they'll come in here.
Oh, this is...
Oh, they can maybe come in here.
This is a good snake.
Will they come in here?
No.
I think I'm good on...
Okay.
Is he circling me?
He's trying...
He's going to eat me?
For real?
Sneak 100?
The snake is going to eat me.
He's circling my feet.
I'm safe inside the snake ring, you guys.
They can't see me inside the snake ring.
Ouroboros.
I can hear them walking around.
I have to see if they're going to come in here.
If they'll sneak past.
I would tranquilize him and take him home if I had any more bullets, but I don't.
I hear them walking.
We might have to actually kill people here.
We might have to kill here.
My river.
No, my river was so clean.
You have the Mosin.
Yeah, but it makes a lot of... It's loud.
It's loud.
Any sea bears around?
Sorry, I'm just going to wait out the caution.
I didn't kill him.
I don't think it counts.
I put him to sleep and then he crashed.
Right?
Like...
I don't think it counts because it wasn't a direct kill of mine.
I'm safe inside the snake ring.
What is the guys?
Oh my god.
What's wrong?
No!
Oh my gosh!
Get out of my hole!
Oh my god!
What's wrong?
Okay, maybe that's all of them, maybe.
How many guys did I put to sleep?
I'm too good at this game.
That's why I'm stuck in a hole, surrounded by a snake.
I should have just grenaded them, huh?
I don't think this guy is leaving.
No way!
What?
I didn't take out that many people!
I can't believe they left.
They had a prototype to MGS4's threat ring system all the way back in Sekiro.
Should I just die and restart?
There's...
Is it bugged?
I didn't put to sleep that many people.
Okay, it's going down much more now.
As long as I don't notice somebody else.
Okay, it's finally going down.
It's finally going down.
And this guy right here!
I'll have to CQC him.
Or maybe I can hold him up and then kill him.
No, I'm just kidding.
I'll CQC him.
I'll make him shimmy for me.
I think that snake is actually Minto.
Minto would totally circle a snake like that.
And I'm eating my own ass.
Nah, the snake's a simp.
Okay, oh my gosh.
Wiggle for me, little guy.
Why is this guy just chilling here?
So what do I do about the worry button?
About the drone people?
Ciphers?
Not ciphers, but you know.
What do I...
What do I do about them?
I just have to be really sneaky?
Make sure they don't see me?
Eee old ciphers.
Cipher.
Reminder, you will never match her for you.
You guys are quite freaky yourselves.
But I like that.
We're all freaks together.
Okay?
Chat reflects the streamer.
Okay, we're almost there.
We're almost there.
Once we get these extra guys gone.
Sorry to just be chilling here for a whole hundred plus seconds.
He might leave once the caution's over.
And... ah!
Alright, let's give him...
Let's give him a couple more seconds.
This snake is so funny.
Oh my god.
This is the original camera angle.
Horrible.
I never would have known that there was a guy there.
I love Minto.
Okay, I hear someone walking.
Quite fast.
I think he's coming down.
Ah!
Are you for real?
You circled me.
You circled me this entire time.
And then you decide to bite me!
Asshole.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Alright guys.
There might be some death here.
So, let me try also this.
Um...
Let's see.
Okay, we have the cigar gas spray.
If I can use it.
How do I use it again?
Let me check.
Um...
Just square to hold.
Okay.
Betrayed by the circle.
Snake circle.
Oh, the irony.
Like...
What a jerk.
And let's um...
Okay.
Instead of a big shooty weapon.
Let's do...
Some maybe smoke grenades.
And instead of...
I'll put away the TNT.
Let's put a book.
Let's grab a book.
Yeah.
Maybe some more distraction stuff.
Than actual...
You know...
Uh...
Okay.
I think he's downstairs.
Never mind.
He's right there.
Uh...
I think he goes downstairs.
I do have good camo.
At least.
Go down!
Leave this place.
What stairs?
You know what I mean.
We're at 90% camo.
We're pretty good.
I hate this part.
Gosh, I hate this part.
What's worse is it's so long even.
But we get a sexy time with Eva it's worth.
Just think of the sexy Eva.
Sexy Eva coming up.
Gonna have...
This on the ready.
Just in case.
Back down.
Alright.
Slow and steady everybody.
Wait for...
I hear the...
I hear him.
Eyes on the prize.
Actually I'm gonna get closer to the wall.
There we go.
No.
Shaw.
Okay.
Why can't you give me anymore?
Please.
Why no more tranq ammo please?
You know what would enhance this camouflage?
Crocodile cam.
So true.
So did these guys come out instead of the helicopter?
Is that what that is?
No one would expect a...
I can't remember.
Where this guy is.
I'm just gonna go for it.
Oh my god.
I think I hear him.
Do I hear him?
I mean I definitely hear him.
Is he coming up?
Oh there he is.
Oh my god.
Try with the OG camera.
Oh my gosh.
It's so good here actually.
OG camera my beloved.
He's going up.
Huh.
I want to get into that hole.
I can't tell if he can see me or not.
I'm gonna wait for him to go back down.
I never thought about this.
Well you wouldn't be able to use it.
Unless you were playing subsistence.
Because they took it out.
Hold on.
Where does this go?
Why am I going down?
Um.
Wait a second.
Why am I?
Where am I?
Is there anything down here?
Never mind.
Turn around.
I think.
I'm just gonna go.
Where is the other guy?
Where did he go?
Oh my gosh.
Where were you?
I need to go.
Oh god.
Which direction is the correct direction?
I hear another person walking.
Maybe it's the guy down here.
I can't tell.
Turn around.
Every now and then I get a little bit lonely And you're never coming round.
Every now and then I get a little bit tired.
Listening to the sound of my...
Oh there he is.
Turn around.
Oh.
Lame.
I think I have to run past this guy.
Um.
Once he turns around again, we'll go.
He stays looking the other direction for quite some time, so.
Every now and then I And I'm gonna go up that way.
Fall apart.
And I need you now tonight.
And I need you more than ever.
I can't tell how far he can see.
If I'm like around a...
Oh yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Mixing.
Mixing the camera angles is kind of amazing.
Alright.
Time to be careful here a little bit.
We don't want...
Okay.
Maybe he won't see me.
Phew.
Guys, we're so stealthy.
Please sing that song next karaoke.
Okay.
Stupid Fiber One commercial ruined the song for me.
Wait, what are you talking about?
You watch commercials?
I don't know the last time I watched TV.
I don't know if he'll see me or not, but...
No, I went the wrong way.
Haha!
No.
Can I fall from here?
I can fall from here.
I can fall from here!
Right game?
Game.
I can fall from here, right?
They won't hear me if I shoot it, will they?
If I shoot the Mosin, will they hear me?
Oh, I forgot I put it away.
Son, you've got a way to fall.
The Mosin isn't silent.
I wouldn't risk it, personally.
It's loud.
I don't trust it.
I don't trust it, either.
How do I get past these guys, though?
Let me change it to my next...
My sunny camouflage.
But then they'll see me for sure, 100%.
Let's eat...
a rabbit.
Not bad.
Pretty tasty.
Throw a chaff beforehand so they don't hear the shot.
I don't even want to...
Oh, Sig spray them.
So true.
I don't even wanna...
do like... I don't wanna...
Where is that thing, anyway?
Can it see me from here?
I don't wanna go into alert mode at all, honestly.
Okay.
Oh my god, he's moving.
Where'd the other guy go?
Oh, there he is.
Gosh, I was just about to drop down.
If I had, this guy would've walked right up on me.
Okay, there.
I don't think he'll be able to see me.
Cool.
Where are you going?
Oh, I don't know if Woodland's the best camo, you're right, for my face.
Guys, I'm at 95%.
That's crazy.
Crazy.
And I'm an animal.
I'm practically invisible.
Alright, once this guy turns around, we'll drop and...
I'll cigarette him.
I have to do it to their face though, right?
Like...
You have to be pretty close.
Maybe when he comes...
Oh my god, who saw me?
Who went, hmm?
Or am I crazy?
Maybe not.
Just kidding.
CQC slam him?
Yeah...
That is an option.
It does work from behind, though.
Okay, cool.
I don't think I've ever used...
I think I've used it like once before.
So I don't quite remember.
Is there a snake around here?
Okay, let's just keep moving.
He's gonna come down like any second though, right?
Yeah, here he comes.
We'll get this guy first.
Wait!
I know.
What
do we have here?
Can I get my book back, or...
Lucky.
I think I saw something.
Did you?
Come here, come here.
Come check it out, come check it out.
Oh, I guess I'm seeing things.
Oh yeah.
Turn around!
I wish I could get my book back.
Oh.
We're fine.
Nobody else is coming.
Oh, shoot.
Why is there a whole ass alarm, huh?
Why is there a whole ass alarm going off?
Oh my god.
Where?
Throwing stuff at me.
Uh...
Hmm...
Owl-cha!
Come inside.
Whoopsie.
I pressed the wrong button.
Snake.
I don't think we're gonna make it, Snake.
I hate this part.
Am I gonna have to do this all over again?
Please, no!
Please, I'd rather die!
Please don't make me do it all over again!
Please!
Uh...
Maybe I should just go to the next area and die.
Hmm...
Let's go to the next area and die.
Oh my gosh.
Bye-bye!
Bye!
Go to the next area!
If I die, I die!
Because I can't go into the next room with Eva unless there's not an alert.
I just have to kill everybody, I guess.
Hahaha.
What if I box, like, right here?
Do you think they notice?
Oh!
I got a new uniform.
Urban environment.
Nice.
Um...
Anyway, so I started blasting.
Uh...
Hmm...
How do I want to do this?
Maybe...
Smoke grenade, box.
Foolproof.
Right!
Oh, wait.
I had it.
Okay, never mind.
Where's my smoke grenade?
There we go.
That's stupid.
They're shooting, but do they know what they're talking...
about?
Oh my god.
Do they even know what they're talking about?
Hahaha.
We're suffering from severe burns, dude.
This is so bad.
Um, what else do I need?
Bandage.
If you lie down, they won't find you?
Oh, that's true, right?
Because I'm at 95 camo?
That's so true.
I boxed out of fear.
Hahaha.
I boxed out of what felt like a necessity.
Let me eat.
Let's have a little snack while we wait.
Oh, it's supposed to taste great!
Nice.
Yeah, that's my safety box, for real.
We're evading.
Let's get rid of the...
We're in caution.
Gosh.
I hate the mountains!
I hate the mountains so much.
Nice camera angle.
I hear footsteps, but I can't...
Actually...
Wait, my camo is not even that great right here.
I just noticed.
Okay, there we go.
Now my camo is good.
Don't see me!
What's the regular...
old camera angle?
It's okay.
Not the best here though.
Gosh, there's so many guys!
This part sucks so much.
To the trench of safety.
I don't know about that!
I don't know about that.
The pre-dug grave.
We have to go up to that building right up there.
Right?
That's the one with Eva in it, right?
Let me call her.
Eva?
Eva, help me, please.
You made it to the mountains.
Yeah, somehow.
Those mountains are known as Krasnogorye.
The name means the Red Mountain Ridge in Russian.
The entire range has been fortified to act as a defense for the great fortress of Krasnogorye.
The area near the top has been dug with bunkers and trenches.
And there are anti-aircraft gun emplacements everywhere.
It's literally an impenetrable wall.
Proceed with caution.
Oh, it's further up, okay.
There's a provision storehouse in the hillside area.
And there's an armory at the summit.
Oh, maybe I saw the armory.
I'll meet you in the ruins at the top of the mountains.
Maybe that's the armory.
See those ruins at the summit?
I'll be waiting for you there.
Yes.
Let's see.
Oh my goodness.
Eva, you're so far away.
Eva.
Why you gotta do this to me?
Guys, somehow we survived.
Metal Gear survived real.
If I go in here though...
I wonder if it will be... maybe... okay.
This might be stupid.
I might be a fool everybody, but I'm going in.
I'm going in!
I'm going into the trenches!
I might be dumb.
They won't see me down here.
Will they?
If I'm wiggling.
Yeah.
Helicopter.
Where is he?
Where'd he go?
Just hug the wall.
Go to the wall.
Okay.
Might be.
Hey.
I know it says 95%, but I just don't trust it.
Rather, I don't trust me.
I don't trust me.
So that's where my worries lie.
...
I'm sensing some PTSD from this corner in particular.
You gnome with the PTSD?
Do you know?
Oh gosh.
I don't know if I'm ready to fight the fury.
Well I have to get there first.
Where
am I?
Where am I?
I'm so lost.
I wish I could zoom in even more.
At least you're not escorting five prisoners.
Oh child.
Prisoners in five.
What are you talking about?
I love escort missions.
You don't like escort missions?
What's wrong with you?
Let's go this way and just see where it takes us.
Into the hole we go.
I hear somebody.
Maybe around this way.
Let's see.
If I go around...
So...
Maybe I just keep following the trench.
Up around this building.
And I can make it.
Very snaky.
I hear someone on my left.
Oh there he is.
Okay.
Hug the wall.
Oh my god.
Never mind.
I'm gonna wait.
I'm gonna wait it out.
The end is coming to a close you guys.
Wait does he come in here?
Oh shit.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
You come in here?
No my hole.
Oh my god.
You guys.
Um...
I can't cigarette spray him.
Just gonna have to go.
Go snake.
Snake go.
Wait, am I going the right way?
I'm way further than I thought!
This map makes no sense to me.
Yeah, I'm out of mark 22 shots.
Yes I am.
I wish I could have...
I wish I could have just...
I wish I could have cigarette sprayed him afterwards, but it wouldn't let me.
He's gonna wake up.
Wait.
I don't want this guy seeing me.
Pick up up for loot!
I can't go back down!
Oh my god.
We made it!
Holy cow!
Oh my god.
Time for Eva.
Hold on.
Let me eat a mint.
You look like you could use some rest.
Oh my god.
She looks naked from behind for real.
It's just that playing these two roles hasn't left me much time to sleep.
Where'd you get those cuts?
Colonel.
He found out?
If he knew I'd be dead already.
No.
This is his hobby.
He's a sadist.
He gets pleasure out of making people suffer.
He's scum.
Does it look that strange to you?
No.
I'm the same way.
Scars all over.
Can I see?
No.
So...
Where'd you get this one?
He's so fast.
I got it after defecting to the Soviet Union.
I don't think so.
It's older than that.
Code breaking is a desk job.
Where'd you get this kind of scar?
You really wanna know?
You wanna know how I got these scars?
Well, too bad.
A girl's gotta have some secrets, you know.
But enough about that.
You've gotta get going.
The phase two trial of the shaggle hot is about to start.
And it looks like someone might be coming to spoil the party.
Uh oh.
Khrushchev?
His forces are on their way here.
The colonel is gathering his troops together to meet them.
If we don't get a move on, the security will be even tighter than it is now.
I should've been naked.
I should've taken off my animal print.
You'll need this key.
Oh, thank you.
It unlocks the door to the underground tunnel.
Once you're in there, you can follow the tunnel to get inside Grozengrad.
Snake really needs to learn how to pick locks.
And take this too.
Oh my gosh, ramen, my favorite.
What is it?
The food of the future.
A well-balanced meal for the space age.
It's good to eat some real food once in a while.
Space food.
Yummy ramen!
I'll bet if I kissed you, you'd taste like a wild beast.
Do you know where exactly in Grozengrad Sokolov is located?
I bet if I kissed you, you'd taste like a wild beast.
Yeah, I've been eating snakes, Eva.
Please.
There's the east wing, which houses the research facilities.
Then there's the main wing, where the weapons are assembled.
That's where the Shagohan is.
Finally, there's the west wing, which is connected via a passageway to the main building.
That's where Sokolov is.
Oh boy, Grozengrad.
To get in, you'll have to enter the main wing from the east wing.
Then go through the passageway on the second floor of the main wing.
The west wing of the weapons lab.
Got it.
There's just one problem.
What?
Not again.
The west wing is protected by the highest level of security.
You need to be Colonel Class to get in.
Colonel Class?
Here.
Major Ivan Raidenovich Rykov.
Raidenovich Rykov?
How do I do that?
Oh my god.
Rykov time.
I love this.
This is the best time ever!
The steel is closed.
You look similar from behind.
You won't know the difference.
Your face might be a problem.
So you just have to figure something out.
He should be somewhere in the east wing.
Oh my god.
You!
Rykov, my beloved.
Yeah, we're both caked up.
They won't even tell the difference.
As long as nobody grabs my crotch.
Command said you're supposed to have something ready for me.
And I do.
A kiss.
There's a lake 30 miles north of here.
A lake.
I hid a wig there.
A wig?
A wig.
It's a state of the art ground effect vehicle.
Oh.
A ground effect vehicle.
She doesn't like my hairstyle.
I can't fly one of those.
That's okay.
I happen to be an excellent pilot.
Taking off from a lake is trickier than it looks.
It's not like riding a motorcycle.
You've got to be more delicate.
Of course I will.
You've seen how good I am with the bike, right?
Right.
You handle the escape then.
I'll head for Groznykrad.
How?
Wait a minute.
There's something I wanted to ask you.
What?
What's the story between you and the boss?
She was like a mother.
And my master.
And your lover?
It went deeper than that.
Deeper?
Half of me belongs to the boss.
Do you love her?
No, nothing like that.
Do you hate her?
Does it have to be one or the other?
Love or hate?
Between a man and a woman?
You bet.
Oh my god, he turns away.
For ten years, we lived and died together.
You couldn't possibly understand.
And you think you can kill her now?
Eva's so hot.
That's your mission, isn't it?
Assassinating the boss?
Mmm...
Oh, Snake...
Snake?
Is there anyone you like?
Oh my god!
I've never been interested in other people's lives.
Anybody you like?
You were interested in the boss?
Sir Catboy?
She was different.
Really?
How do you feel about me?
I should be asking you the same question.
Me?
I can fall in love.
If it's part of the mission.
Even with you.
Oh my god.
He just has no shame.
He has no shame.
He just looks.
Snake, your mind is elsewhere.
Snake, please, I'm kissing you.
Oh my god, he just does not even reciprocate.
Even a little bit.
He's like a tuna.
He's just a dead fish right there.
Snake!
He's like, this isn't part of the mission.
That wasn't me!
It wasn't me!
A tuna?
I say that because that's what they call fans.
Or rather, they used to.
I don't know if they still do.
But they used to call fans at idol shows that would just kind of stand there and do nothing.
And just watch the show with their arms crossed.
Or not cheering.
Not having pen lights or anything like that.
They called them maguro.
And so I just...
Just adopted it.
Standing man emoji.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm definitely a maguro then.
However you want to enjoy the concert is up to you.
There she goes.
Oh my gosh.
I hope you see us a lot.
Oh no.
I'm feeling it in my ectoplasm.
Get out of there!
Or don't.
Hehehehe.
Hoorah!
Oh!
His shoes!
Colonel.
Hey, talk.
Why were you walking like that?
I died before I could get it out of him.
His arms are like so wide apart.
Hehehe.
Was it the spy then?
Mmm.
Oh yeah, nice shoes.
Oh!
Or...
Look at this.
Transmitter?
Exactly.
I had to keep someone informed of his location.
Dun dun.
But...
Does this mean Granon was the spy?
Oh my gosh, I can't wait to see this guy.
Perhaps he was being used by someone else.
Perhaps.
The way he moves, everything.
Oh my god!
I love Ocelot so much.
I don't approve of your methods.
I don't need your approval.
I'm in command here.
Yeah.
Oh my god, the tension.
And that nuclear shell.
He's always pointing.
He's such a theater kid.
I know!
This is war, Major.
The Cold War.
Fought with information and espionage.
We must root out spies wherever they hide.
It is kill or be killed.
All the guys have blue eyes.
Have you noticed that?
Potential threats must be weeded out.
They're all staring into my soul.
Your feelings are a menace to the unity of our organization.
Someone is guiding the enemy's hand.
A single man can only accomplish so much.
Ooh.
Make no mistake.
There is a spy among us.
But casting suspicion on our old comrades.
The C3 explosives have been stolen.
You think it was the American?
No.
He could not have reached this fortress yet.
Who?
I'd be careful about suspicions.
Well, I guess Vulcan doesn't have blue eyes.
But they're, like, brighter, you know?
Boss.
Where have you been?
You smell.
Fear and the End have fallen.
No!
Ooh, you couldn't get the End's weapon because I have it.
Damn it!
Don't worry.
He won't be able to get past the Fury because it's the worst enemy.
That leaves only the Fury.
How can the legendary Cobras be beaten so easily?
He's gotta spin some...
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
I'll take care of him.
Oh my god.
What is he after?
Must be more than just Sokolov.
America is out to destroy the Shagahod and get its hands on your inheritance.
It was very silent there.
The Philosopher's Legacy.
Impossible.
The Legacy.
It...
Kuwabara, Kuwabara.
Then they're out to kill me as well.
Colonel, tighten the security on this place.
Boss.
He's coming here.
I'm sure of it.
I'm gonna get the Davy Crockett.
Kuwabara, Kuwabara.
I like how...
How...
Eva's just kind of standing there.
She's just like, what do I do now?
Hmm?
Oh, he's gonna snuff her.
Perfume.
Points.
She's like, taking a mental note of that for your birthday.
You are such a freak.
This guy is such a freak.
He's such a freak.
Oh my god.
He's so freaky.
Nice boots.
Oh.
Oh, it's got the scuff.
I'm sure you polished them up properly.
Points.
We need like a point encounter.
How many times does he point at people?
I bet he smells snake on her.
That's the perfume.
It's snake's cologne.
Goat musk.
Oh my gosh.
Cheetah print.
It's not Eva.
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry.
What's her name?
Tatiana.
Oh.
Hello, Krasnigrad.
Wait, can you see like the little guys walking around at this part?
This place is empty.
Oh, Kerotan.
Oh, there's a guy.
You think I can snipe him?
These tanks look like little M&M's.
Do it.
Okay, well definitely with the fury, we're just...
Actually, I don't want to even prank him.
I want to just take him out.
Viewers are commenting on the streamer's fidgeting.
Silence in a parent person.
A parent, eh?
Hmm.
Okay, YouTube.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, how do I zoom in again?
There we go.
Oh my god, I really could get his butt.
I could get his butt.
Such a waste of bullets.
It's such a waste of bullets.
Goodnight!
You could even see the little zzz's from all the way over here.
Don't fall.
How did she get...
from here...
all the way...
Huh...
The zzz's.
Oh, it's been a while since I've called Colonel and stuff, so let's see.
I wonder if there's a silencer for the Mosin.
That would be incredible.
Tatyana.
Oh.
Miss Paramedic, don't worry, we'll get to her next.
What does Paramedic have to say?
What are these?
Selenoyars.
Oh.
That means she really likes it because it looks like something... a shiitake mushroom.
Yeah, will it recharge my batteries?
It's a luminescent.
Alright, let's save real quick.
Yes, actually, please.
So, the third slide...
What?
Don't save over that one.
I don't like mushrooms.
I don't like any mushrooms.
I hate mushrooms.
20,000 leagues under the sea?
I love that ride at Disney.
After a number of battleships mysteriously sink at sea, the American government investigates and finds that the culprit is this pacifistic Captain Nemo.
I'm afraid of mushrooms.
The scene where the giant squid attacks Captain Nemo's submarine, the Nautilus, is breathtaking.
But also, I don't like when they're really slimy, you know?
And it was great to see it on the big screen.
A giant squid, huh?
Giant squid?
What?
Don't tell me you think it sounds tasty.
Which way do I go again?
Do I just... do I go down?
I can't remember.
Do I just go down?
Funny codec if you eat the mushroom.
Oh, okay.
Wait, I gotta eat the mushroom.
Back through the door.
You can't make me, you can't make me.
You can't make me!
Oh, here it is.
A uroluminescent mush... mushroom.
Eat.
Paramedic, it's poisonous.
Oh, paramedic!
I contracted food poisoning from eating naturally poisonous food.
Use an antidote.
Paramedic!
You lying...
I thought you were supposed to be a doctor.
By the way, paramedic.
Yeah?
What?
I tried that uroluminescent mushroom you were talking about.
So how did it taste?
Like urinal.
It was poisonous.
More like urinal luminescent.
What?
It was a poison mushroom.
Really?
Yeah.
That's weird.
The guide says it's...
Are you sure that guide is reliable?
Don't worry.
It's fine.
It just happened to be wrong this one time.
It was poisonous.
Let's go.
Oh, I forgot to get my ramen noodles.
Alrighty.
Come on, please!
Give me more bullets.
Wait, what's under there?
Bullets?
Bullets, for sure.
Oh!
Andragos, thank you for the 20 gift!
Thank you!
Oh, wait.
This is gonna show me just in here.
Yeah.
Okay.
No.
Mark 22.
So sad.
Guess I'll die.
I don't remember Mark 22 ammo being this rare.
Right!
Why would they think I'm using so many other things?
I don't know.
It's craziness.
All right.
Where do I need to go?
To the...
X marks the spot.
Okay.
Here we go.
Here we'll sneaky crawl.
Oh, okay.
Camera angle kind of messed me up there.
Oh, gosh!
There's another guy up there.
There's a guy up there.
No.
Oh, there you are.
Shake down the guard.
Yeah.
But that would...
I could shake them down, yes.
That is a thing.
Shaking them down.
That would require me holding them up, though.
And we're going to kill that back.
And once I put away my gun, they can shoot me, right?
Crazy last night, I'm processing the pics now.
So much Ota was hella hype.
Should I post under Fantography or use a...
Oh!
What is...
Oh my god, oh no!
Oh, I forgot about the Flamethrower, guys!
Oh, we are so in trouble.
Get out of here.
Oh my god.
Controlling it with this camera angle.
Oh god, I gotta be fast though.
I don't wanna get in his walking path, you know?
Maybe I could take him down from behind.
Sorry.
You will be in the river.
Sorry, you'll be in the river.
Sorry.
You'll be in the river.
I'll remember you.
I'll remember you when I see you in the river.
Loot him?
Oh yeah, you're right.
Is this guy coming down too?
Oh yeah, he is.
Oh shoot, you guys.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hold on.
I'll go... Oh wait, he's gonna see him, isn't he?
Wait, I think I'm in trouble.
Is he gonna see him dead on the ground?
Um...
Guys?
Nothing?
Uh...
Who's that?
cam on my ass!
Um... I'm on fire.
Oh my god,
I'm getting... I don't know about you!
I'm getting deja vu!
What?
Someone's on fire.
I'm feeling real deja vu right now.
I'm like right next to it.
But I have to pass it!
Okay.
Okay, let's go back.
Let's just wait it out here.
Oh, let me treat my burns.
I'm not ready for...
I'm not ready.
I need more ointment.
Friendly fire.
I know, right?
This guy.
Are they gonna see that guy's dead body and then get mad again?
You've lost the enemy.
Enter high alert.
Don't look in yet.
No, I'm not.
I've literally...
I'm so far.
I'm so gone.
Why is it called that?
It's not friendly at all.
It's... you're... you're... you're...
Um... you... I never got to loot that guy.
It's towards your friends.
That's why.
You're not gonna peek in here, are you?
Oh my god.
What was that?
Oh my god!
That's a dead guy right there!
Ah!
The birds are eating him!
What's
wrong?
Oh my god!
You were not gonna...
That... that was not me!
That was literally you!
You can't say what's wrong!
You killed him!
I didn't kill him!
No.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
What's wrong?
Oh my god.
Eat the bird.
What do you mean what's wrong?
What's wrong?
I didn't kill him!
Why do we keep getting into these what's wrong loops?
We're innocent!
It wasn't me!
What's wrong?
Well, we're like right next to where we need to go, right?
What?
Let me see.
Hold on.
If I come out of the trenches, we're like so close.
What's wrong loop?
We're in another what's wrong loop?
Why does this keep happening to me?
Your honor, he died of friendly fire.
I swear!
I didn't commit the war crimes!
I only killed one guy!
Oh my god.
I hate this part.
The caution status in this room always resets for no reason.
It's so wild.
It's so stupid.
I'm going to have a mint.
Or rather like a cough drop.
Oh, the birds are eating him.
They're eating him.
And then I'm going to eat them.
Oh my god.
If I shot this bird...
R-word.
I have to wait, though.
Yeah, it's a dog eats dog world out there.
I mean, the guy is already cooked.
What a perfect opportunity to eat my first ever man, right?
He's already been...
Shut up.
Too slow.
I'm waiting it out.
I don't want to get burned alive.
Let's wait for another bird.
Surely one will come.
And we'll get that bird instead.
Another.
Come on, birds!
Birds!
Fresh meat right here!
For you, pre-cooked.
It's a barbecue.
Oh my god, see?
They're about... they're gonna leave soon, though.
Don't say what's wrong.
You killed that guy.
I didn't kill that guy.
And over.
Unable to determine the problem is kind of wild.
I think you know the problem very well, actually.
Oh, they're still leaving.
Oh, that was close.
Okay.
I don't want to waste the battery.
Boom, boom, boom.
Yeah, it's just a mystery.
Whatever could have happened to that guy.
Okay, so there is someone right here.
And I need to exit.
Okay, he turned around.
Okay, I'm done.
Let's see.
If I leave this spot, and I go up there, and then go to the door.
I don't think I really feel like waiting, honestly, for a bird.
Because he's walking away.
Might be my chance.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Human meat tastes like pork.
We call it long pig.
What do you mean weird?
What do you mean?
Who's weird?
Bats.
Oh, no.
The bats!
That's such a cool...
That's the original angle, though.
That's such an awesome angle instead of this.
You can get the bats in full view.
This is cinema.
This is a cinematic, you know.
Sorry.
I like going back and forth.
Between them.
Oh, you guys.
Oh.
I'm gonna be sick.
Saving the game, Snake?
Yeah.
Snake, have you ever seen the beast from 20,000 Fathoms?
What's up with 20,000?
It's about this monster that comes to life from 20,000 fathoms.
It's deep within a glacier as a result of an H-bomb test in the Arctic.
It crosses the ocean and emerges in New York.
Cool.
I especially like the scene where the monster attacks the lighthouse.
And the one where it pops out of a valley in Manhattan and makes a big hole in a building.
Spoilers.
And the last scene on the green roller coaster was simply incredible.
And because I saw it in a drive-in theater, I actually felt like I was a part of the movie.
Oh.
It's funny, isn't it?
How you can let yourself get absorbed into these things without thinking...
YouTube AI is stupid.
Distinguishing between what's real and what's not isn't always as simple as we think.
Well, don't get too absorbed in your mission.
It's important to take a rest every now and then.
Okay, Mei-Ling.
Let's see how Eva's doing.
Eva?
Put on your gear before you go?
Yeah, I know.
No response.
She's busy.
Follow that tunnel to the north and you'll come out inside Groznygrad.
Keep going north.
You could be fighting the furry.
Siggint.
Yo.
Yeah.
Eva said she set up a ground effect vehicle for us to make our escape.
Oh, yeah.
A wig.
So I heard.
The ground effect vehicle or wig...
Will you wear wigs?
...is something like a cross between an airplane...
Do you wear wigs?
...and a boat.
It uses ground effect to fly.
Ground effect basically means you can fly.
Ground effect basically means that when the craft skims the surface of the ground, the air between the ground and the wing is compressed, which gives the wing an extra boost.
From what Western intelligence agencies have been able to gather, the Russians are pretty serious about developing these wigs.
When will you wear wigs?
Apparently, they're planning on using them for anti-submarine patrols.
I guess I can see why.
The wigs' long cruising range and high-speed capabilities make it a good choice for that kind of mission.
Eva must have gotten her hands on one of the first prototypes while it was being built.
How do you just transport it?
The wing has a top speed of over 400 miles per hour.
But you stick it in your pocket?
And its range is pretty good, too.
Like, how do you get that here?
Not that speed is gonna help you if you've got a supersonic fighter jet on your tail.
But if you hug the surface and stay off the radar, you should have no problems getting away.
Oh, okay.
How do we just...
Okay.
Oh...
Well, I guess that's it.
I wish I could be Moss.
I'll go with the tires.
Oh, splitter.
And...
We'll go with...
Splitter, splitter!
Looks so good.
Oh my gosh.
It looks so good.
Okay.
Let's add a flashlight.
Why?
Why is it so hard?
And not that I'm gonna use them here or anything, but still, why is it so hard?
Oh, I see.
I love how they give you one ointment and one bandage.
Like, here you go.
That's all you need.
You put the boat in inventory.
It's simple.
Finally!
Oh gosh.
As soon as I go down there...
I don't wanna go.
I'm just gonna get all my Blast-y weapons.
I'm just gonna get all my Blast-ing weapons, you know?
We'll keep that, just in case.
Oh wait, what was the thing that I picked up that was really good?
Well, we can keep the shotgun.
Was it the 63?
M63?
You've improved so much since then, you got this, Minto?
Thank you!
M63, yeah yeah, okay.
We'll take...
Oh okay, just kidding.
What's a WP grenade?
Wait, what is that?
What is that?
Looks like I got here just in time for a fire, fire, fire.
Fire grenade, oh!
That's crazy.
Let's get rid of our book.
Take the SVD, I guess I could do that too.
Oh yeah, probably would be good to...
do that from far away and get them from as far as I can.
I'm getting a stomach ache.
I am... I am...
I am... I am not looking forward to this so much.
I'm getting a stomach ache, oh god.
You say welcome to Ravager, thank you!
Oh, you look so cool though.
Yeah, kill the bats!
Kill the bats!
I am the fury!
The flames of my rage will incinerate you.
I know, I also am filled with rage.
I can't face.
As I returned, I had one vision.
The world set ablaze.
Maybe the theory and I have more in common.
What'd you see?
Fury!
Yeah!
He's blastin' off!
A grace, a terrible fury at being alive.
Now, you're going to feel the scorching heat of that horrible blackness.
God, no!
God, please, no!
I don't want to do it!
No!
I don't want to do this!
Where is he?
I can't which... tell which way he's coming by.
Oh, there he is.
Oh my gosh.
I'm... you guys, I'm freezing up.
I'm freezing up!
I think he's coming down this... I can't tell if he turned.
The music is so awesome.
It's a little like MGS2.
Why is my suffering cute?
I don't remember what the strat is here.
So, we'll just...
Blast him.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Did he see me?
Is he coming down the same...?
Oh, there he is.
Wait, I can maybe get him from...
Wait, shoot.
Where are you hiding?
Could he see me?
Like this?
Oh, uh... wait.
Ow!
You bastard.
I forgot completely that there's an area over there.
He took off...
He took off right as I was trying to get him.
That's crazy.
Just missed him, I know.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna go as... I'm gonna take it kinda nice, slow and easy, you know?
Cause I'm nervous, so...
I saw him.
I saw him walk by.
That window.
Right there in the corner... Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Don't do it.
OG camera's good here?
Oh, I think I'm... I think I'm... I think I'm... I think I'm gonna...
Not right now.
Don't do it.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh.
Ouchie, ouch.
Get out of the fire.
Probably should get out of the fire.
I tried to kill him again.
I tried to get him more, but you know, whatever.
Burns.
My ointment.
And my bandage.
Get.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
I need a new spot.
Everything's on fire.
Can you, like, not set things on fire?
Wait.
Hold on.
Um.
Where are the...
Like this.
There we go.
Wait.
Why didn't it...
Is it this one?
Aren't they supposed to, like...
Fury.
Oh.
Aren't they supposed to spit water?
Why didn't it...
Wrong pipes.
Oh.
It needs to be lethal.
This is lethal.
No.
I used the shooty gun.
Oh.
Let me turn off my suppressor though.
It's not the tranquilizer.
It's like you...
I put my tranquilizer away, you guys.
It's not the tranquilizer.
Different pipes.
Okay.
Where is he?
Oh my god.
There he is.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Where is he?
Ah!
Oh no!
No!
I got stuck on the wall!
Snake!
I got stuck on the wall.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Food.
Huh.
My shoe's been ripped.
Yeah.
I know.
Where
are you?
Oh.
There you are.
Uh.
Anyways.
Let's start blasting.
Oh my god.
That was close.
Stop following me!
Where?
We're over where?
Under where?
He didn't see me, right?
Ow!
My god, it goes through the walls!
Oh my god, that's so unfair.
Please, snake.
Holy cow.
Bandage.
Wait a minute.
I need to heal more.
I'm gonna eat...
I don't have anything that's like small.
The poison dart frog.
Tell it all where he's at.
Oh my gosh, there he is.
Oh gosh.
I'm trying to go to places that don't...
Where?
I gotta eat something.
I mean...
I gotta like get my health up.
We don't eat those instant noodles.
It's fine.
I know, I know.
I know you like that.
I have no life metal.
Fuck you!
Oh my god, snake, go up.
Go up, go up, go up, go up.
Snake!
I'm not recovering enough health.
I'm not recovering...
Wait.
Oh.
Is there anything in my backpack?
Life med!
Where are you?
Where is it?
I see...
Oh, there it is.
The first thing.
Oh, I did have it.
Okay, just kidding.
I already had it equipped.
Oh my god, this guy has one HP left.
Where are you hiding?
Where?
Okay.
Come here, come here, come here.
Wait, this guy has literally one HP left.
Fury, please.
.
I need a snack.
Die bastard.
This is revenge.
This is revenge!
All those years ago...
Ground Control Command.
Snake get out of there!
He's gonna...
His spirit... is too angry.
Part 2!
Okay, phase two of the battle everybody.
Can
you imagine?
The FURI!
What the FURI?
Whoa!
Oh my god!
Yeah!
I actually did it first try.
I don't know if you guys know, but that fight... used to take me hours.
Oh my god!
I actually did it first try!
Guys, am I a gamer?
Oh my god!
Come here, little rat.
Oh my god.
Oh.
It's too fast.
Come here.
Rat!
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
I'm still shaking though.
What if I just fell?
I could land onto that platform down there.
Rat!
Oh, another one.
I'll do it again.
Non-lethal.
Look, if I wasn't on like survival horror game mode with my... with my... with my tranq bullets right now, I would... you're getting stronger.
I'm getting stronger.
Oh my gosh.
Was not bad.
Little rat.
Okay.
Now let's...
We can...
Get our guns.
Oh, whoops.
Keep this.
You.
We'll...
We'll keep you.
You.
And you.
That's eight out of eight.
Yeah.
Okay.
And...
I think we're good here.
Oh my gosh.
That life...
Thanks for reminding me of that.
Thanks for reminding me about the life stuff.
I always forget because...
Because it's not like a...
It's not like regular rations, you know?
I feel like the Fury could have survived and went home if he didn't act like such a goober and turn himself into a flaming face thing.
I don't know.
All of them, I guess, could have gone home, right?
Ooh, it's cold.
Fury is either easy or hard.
No in between.
Yeah.
We did it.
Oh my gosh.
I can't believe it.
He did go home.
Yeah.
He said, I'm going home.
Oh my god.
I can't believe I beat him.
In the first try.
That's been every boss' first try.
I think really...
Actually, the...
The...
Maybe the...
Fear...
No, not fear.
The pain has caused me the most grief.
He's the one that took me the longest.
You got pretty good at this.
Yippee!
Oh, wow.
I just went...
I had him.
I can't believe he's holding on to one HP for so long.
And that...
Wait.
Wasn't the...
Oh.
I think this is the best camouflage we can have.
I like to have the splinter face with the splinter body.
Okay.
This is a bit good enough.
And I can't believe I missed so many times.
I was trying to shoot him.
You've finally made it inside Grozingrad.
I finally made it inside Grozingrad.
Finally.
Stay alert.
This is the enemy's main base.
Security here is on a scale you haven't encountered yet.
Don't say that.
No kidding.
Your objective is the weapons lab.
It's the giant building in the center of the fortress.
Okay.
Sokolov is in the west wing of that building.
To get into the area where Sokolov is imprisoned...
Now we gotta go find...
You'll need to find Major Rykov.
Steal his clothes and disguise yourself as him.
Yes.
Rykov is supposed to be in the east wing of the weapons lab.
Start out by sneaking into the east wing of the weapons lab.
Then neutralize Rykov and take his clothes.
Take his clothes.
The weapons lab is...
The weapons lab is to the northeast of the area you're in now.
Head northeast.
Gosh.
They...
Okay.
I'm thinking about it even more now with the moss camouflage.
They're just like, you can use it in the sun.
It'll replenish your stamina.
And I'm like, first of all, you give it right at the end of the forest.
Or sorry.
I'm sorry.
The jungles.
And then also, it's nighttime now.
This game is such a troll.
They're like, yeah, you have like the best camo now.
But also, you can't use it.
Like...
You ever think about how in the beginning, all the Cobra unit helped kidnap Sokolov, but the Fury isn't there?
Do you think they're all embarrassed by him?
He's too heavy for the plane.
Or for the helicopter they were in.
Never give up.
Fight until the end.
Always believe you will succeed.
Even when the odds are against you.
Those are...
Big...
Bosh's words.
I need a break.
Looks like you're wearing the Splitter pattern camo.
Let's just talk to some people while I eat a little bit.
Splitter was used quite a bit in World War II on German aircraft and stuff.
The pattern helped mask the plane's attitude and direction in dogfights.
Even now, it's still being used as camouflage in some places.
It works best when you wear it against a steel or stone background.
Oh, God.
Eat food to recover stamina.
That's what I'm doing.
Two.
Speaking of trolling, the Fury's camo makes you immune to fire.
That's so messed up.
Would it make you immune to like...
Not a grenade.
That's an explosion.
Ow.
Woke up.
Okay.
All right.
Let's see.
Where are we going?
Oh, wait.
Let me save.
Sorry.
I forgot to save.
Okay.
Do you want to save?
Yes.
Please, please, please.
Please let me save.
I do not want to fight him again.
Good crunch.
It's some of my snacks I got from Japan.
These ones are potato sticks.
They're Koi Kea Stick Potato.
It's a...
Just a...
Snake, have you seen the magnificent...
A snake?
It's just a flavor.
Sorry.
It's just potato flavor.
It's a remake of the Japanese classic, The Seven Samurai, only in a western setting.
Oh, she doesn't like it that much, then.
This tiny Mexican village is attacked every year by bandits.
That's so sad.
Finally, the village elder can't stand it any longer and decides to hire someone to protect the village.
Oh.
Do it yourself.
Seven gunmen respond to the call.
They teach the villagers how to shoot and prepare for the oncoming attack.
But then, the enemy shows up at the village with a huge band.
Then what happens?
You'll just have to see it for yourself.
Respect for playing on original hardware.
Thank you.
No.
Movies are only fun when you actually watch them.
They're something you have to experience for yourself.
The memory card, though, that I had, I don't think it's...
It's not mine.
I don't know whose it is.
It might be...
It might be, like, either my dad's or my sister's husband.
I don't know.
Uh...
Because I didn't...
I was like, these are not my games.
So, I just had it.
Could you imagine if Fury's helmet came off and he was a ridiculous Ikemen?
Let's see.
Oh.
Now the map.
Sorry.
I don't know.
Um...
Who's this is?
Whoa...
Zoom out?
Oh.
We can't zoom out?
We gotta go to the big building, right?
The big building!
What a way to end...
a night...
an off-season.
Kudos to me and the Wisps at Otake section at the Atrium for making my first ever concert.
Yep!
Oh, hype.
I thought you said yippee.
Marvel, thank you!
I'm so glad you had fun!
Now that the flamethrowers are dead, I hope you don't mind, but I wanted to check.
Should I use Phantography?
Oh!
That's right!
I'm sorry, Seymour.
You asked earlier and then I completely forgot to answer your question.
Um...
You could use Phantography or you could use the general hashtag, too.
Whichever works.
Now that we have Twitter and the whole thing, let's go.
Even though Kojima loves movies, Paramedic makes more sense.
We had...
We had GAME FAX before.
What are you talking about?
We had the GAME FAX telling us all the real information.
Please, Morran.
That's a smoke grenade.
I'm gonna just creep and crawl under here.
We're just gonna not be seen by this guy.
Hey...
Real quick.
Oh, he's coming real close.
He's right up on me.
Oh, let me also put my suppressors back on.
Okay, this one has a suppressor.
The T-Rex pose is so cute.
I know!
Gosh, he's just like me for real.
Oh Snake, you silly guy.
I wish I could see the other guy over here.
Oh, he's gone.
Where'd he go?
Can't see your head.
Got him.
We'll
loot him though.
There's dogs here too, aren't there?
Forgot about the dogs.
You know Kojima loves movies.
The character Snake comes from Escape from New York.
Yeah, the box art ripped from Terminator.
Oh wait, really?
I didn't know about the Terminator bit.
I know Escape from New York, obviously.
Maybe I shouldn't be so loud.
Maybe I should be quiet.
Okay, we gotta go like there-ish.
There's like stuff under here though, isn't there?
Probably.
There's all sorts of loot around here.
Oh, no, just kidding.
There's no loot around here.
I'm a liar.
Quiet is playable?
Yeah.
There's a secret bikini option.
Am I crazy or just quiet?
Quiet does have an Eva outfit, doesn't she?
Oh, oh, oh!
Who's that?
No.
Oh, shi-
What's going on?
No!
Oh, it's a sniper wolf outfit, that's right.
That would make more sense because she's a sniper, right?
Gosh, it really takes a lot to die, huh?
It's okay, Snake.
What about Snake?
Actually, I'm gonna use this time to walk around.
Bye!
Oh, my God!
You have a knife!
Let's check out the area.
Wait, is this working?
No way this is working.
Do not go into evasion.
No way.
Did this work?
Oh, my God.
What the hell?
Why is it so easy?
They're still on my ass, though.
Oh, my God.
Wait, who's on me?
Ouch!
Bye!
It's okay if I die, you guys.
I'm not trying to live, honestly.
The dogs!
Oh, my God, it's the dogs.
It's the dogs.
What if I go inside?
Snake is really just taking it, isn't he?
It's kind of impressive.
Oh, ouch.
Oh, he do.
Okay.
Okay, let's try that again.
That was all my fault.
I completely fumbled the holdup, so I feel...
Oh.
Oh, I died in another area.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
This is not...
Okay.
I didn't actually want to...
Um...
Uh...
Disinfect?
I didn't actually want to use my staff.
Oh, well.
Okay.
I see something over there.
I can't...
I think it's like the dog sleeping.
There's a spotlight.
Where are the people?
I'm gonna...
Sorry, I'm gonna thermal goggle real quick.
Oh, there's a purple.
There's the people.
Oh.
There you go.
Okay.
There's the people.
There's another people.
Can I...
Will they hear me?
If I were to do this?
Oh, the dogs definitely hear that.
But he's gonna go down.
And the dogs awake.
And the dogs...
Where's the dogs?
Oh.
Ow!
The dogs!
That's the dogs.
The dogs.
The dogs!
I hate my life.
I hate my afterlife.
I hate my life-life.
I hate everything.
Shut up, dog!
Shut up!
Why are there two of you?
Oh, uh, lesson learned.
Don't wake up the dog.
I remember going to school.
Going over here one time... and just waiting it out... kinda worked, actually.
You can't get me, dog!
You can't get me anybody.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I'm stuck.
There we go.
A snake.
Wait, I'm actually stuck.
Hello?
There's a snake.
There we go.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Can I go down here?
Evasion.
Yeah, you did.
Will you find him, though?
I'm in the pipes.
I'm in your walls.
Where the hell is this building?
Was it the one that I saw?
Or is it on the other side?
I can't remember.
Gosh.
Box time.
No, they can't come in here.
They're actually dumb.
Get in from another area.
Door's stuck.
This is where we go afterwards, isn't it?
The dog is asleep!
Aren't you supposed to be sniffing around for me?
Aren't you supposed to be doing your job, dog?
Stupid dog.
Oh!
Let me ask if this is the right area...
X-E-R-A!
To get into the area where Sokoliouf is imprisoned, you'll need to find Major Rykoff, steal his clothes, and disguise yourself as him.
Rykoff is supposed to be in the East Wing of the weapon's lab.
Eeeeeast wing.
Start out by sneaking into the East Wing of the Weapons Lab.
We're in the W-East wing.
We're in the W-East Wing.
Then neutralise Rykoff, and take his clothes.
The weapons lab is to the east of the area you're in now.
Okay.
Thank you, Colonel.
Major.
Sorry.
No one's around.
I think I can just sneak in.
Do I have any...
Any camo that's better?
Nope.
Splinter with Splinter.
My beloved.
Is it like the Gator?
Oh, no, no, no.
Wrong gun.
Oh my
gosh.
I got him out of the way at least.
Oh!
Nice!
East.
Oh my gosh.
I just saw that guy.
Crawly crawl crawl.
Sneaking mission.
Where's the door to the east?
I can't go in through this door.
Come on.
Nice.
We're in the clear, baby.
Snake.
Can I get up there?
I'll take it.
I'll take
it.
Give me your food.
I'll take it though.
I will take it.
I will eat.
Right now.
I'll eat your nasty rations.
Sick.
I'm gonna throw up.
So gross.
So I really can't go in through this door.
It really won't let me.
Not even if I knock.
Oh my god.
Wait.
He's on one left.
Did I get him?
Uh...
Pressure?
There we go.
Nice.
Yeah.
I know the spotlight.
I'm looking out for it.
Okay.
Let's go back.
The way we came.
I guess.
Let's go back.
The way we came.
I guess.
I had so much fun being part of the Hamtaro circle last night.
I wish I was still in that circle as I head off to work now.
Good luck with work.
Good luck.
Alrighty.
So...
East.
Can I go through this big door?
There was another door?
There was?
Are you sure?
Wait.
Yes.
Go back?
Okay.
I didn't see it.
Why are I?
There's a cute door I saw shaped like a male cow.
It was a door...
It was a door of a bull.
Huh?
Where is it?
That one right there?
Oh!
This one right here.
Thanks guys.
I'm a little blind.
Oh!
Adorable!
Ah!
I get it.
Oh my goodness.
What a strange location to be starting at.
Anyone around?
Oh I see two guys.
That's where I...
That's where I need to go?
Maybe that door right there?
Oh gosh.
Aim.
Aim, aim, aim.
Got him.
What's wrong?
Anyone else?
I'm looking, I'm looking.
Okay.
I'm gonna snipe him.
I'm gonna snipe him somehow.
Before he... Oh shit.
What's wrong?
Got him.
Anyone else?
Pepee!
I think we're good.
Oh my god.
Watch out for the...
Go back.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
There's another guy.
Motion detector lied to me.
Please.
Woo!
That was close.
That was so close.
Baby.
Honk.
Me, me, me, me, me.
Everybody honk me, me, me.
I'll take that.
Absolutely.
I'll wait for you.
Thank you, Metal Gear.
Thank you, Super-chan.
Thank you.
I love how the spotlight doesn't even like notice him.
Where's the door again?
Oh, there's that guy over there.
Is that the door I need to go into?
Where's it over here?
I can't remember.
I remember it...
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Okay.
Actually, there's...
Uh, sorry.
I'm gonna use thermal.
Okay.
Just this guy.
Eesha!
Anyone else?
Oh, I almost missed this.
Nice.
You hear an alarm.
It's like a ring.
It's a ring.
The spotlight guy isn't paying enough, right?
He's like, I honestly couldn't care less.
East wing!
La la la la la.
From here, we must find Rykov, my beloved.
Our olive drab.
How drab.
The scientist this guy can work here?
Are you sure?
Leandra!
Welcome to my bishop.
Thank you.
It does?
I don't remember.
Am I getting one guide?
Who knows?
What if Rykov just decide... Oh my god.
Look how handsome he is!
What if he just decided to cosplay as a scientist for today, you know?
Oh my god.
Look how handsome he is with the glasses!
I need riding in glasses stat.
I guess we'll test it.
I'm just a scientist.
Pay no mind to me.
Just a lowly scientist.
Looking for my master.
What do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
That's where I gotta put him.
In the lockers.
Don't go in there.
Oh!
I found him!
Wait.
Hold on.
One second.
Nothing?
Oh my god.
No way.
No, no, no.
Let's go grab him.
Come on.
We gotta go.
Oh my god.
Oh wait.
Someone just opened a door?
We're okay.
No one will notice.
If they notice, well...
Just redo.
Yes!
Easy!
That was so easy!
Oh la la!
Rykov!
And your tiny whities!
Oh my god!
Why is it gotta be a thong?
Oh my god.
Volgan, you dog!
You are...
Volgan, you are so nasty.
Oh my chat froze.
One second, guys.
I think YouTube is at it again.
YouTube's at it again with their silliness.
We are 100% foolproof, baby.
Are you okay?
Are you okay in there?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Put him back in.
Please.
Put him back in, please.
Put him back in.
Can you please do that?
I just wanted to see the poster.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Let me fix my chat real quick.
Sorry guys.
I can't see you guys.
It's all frozen.
I refresh.
Oh.
YouTube is like really...
Why has YouTube been so weird for me lately?
Like it's not loading at all or anything.
I don't know why it's been so weird.
Ah, your Rykov disguise has turned out nicely.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Not even his own mother could tell the difference.
Indeed.
You're starting to irritate me already.
Why?
I wouldn't bet on it, but whatever.
Now that you're indistinguishable from the real Rykov, you'll be able to get into the west wing, to which only Volgin and Rykov have access.
Head for the west wing of the weapons lab.
That's where Sokolov is being held.
West wing.
Enter the main wing from the second floor of the east wing.
Pass west through the main wing and you'll come to a connecting passageway.
The west wing is at the other end of that passageway.
Have you been glitching this entire stream?
No way.
I'm so sorry.
Infiltrate the west wing and rescue Sokolov.
Okay.
Reacting to a female character wearing a thong with a lightning bolt on it.
They are commenting on the...
No!
It went away!
They are commenting on the unusual fashion choice and some are joking about the character's sexuality.
Okay.
Let's run around, baby.
Get out!
Alright.
Let's beat up some people.
Finally, I can take out my anger.
I can finally take out my anger.
Where are you?
In the bathroom?
Who's peeing?
Anybody pooping?
No one?
Anybody?
Yeah.
You're welcome.
Keep up the fine work, sir.
Smack you!
What?
Why do you act like that?
A scorpion!
Submachine gun.
Let's go.
Oh.
No.
There we go.
My bullet...
More stuff.
Is your commander jumping on things again?
Of course.
Doing my parkour.
Oh, nice!
He never just slaps once.
Just don't bring up Texas!
Yeah, don't bring up Texas, you guys.
Yeah,
don't bring up Texas, you guys.
I hear them walking around.
Do they hear me or are they just like, He's really going crazy in there.
What if I blew this place up?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
What's going on?
What do you mean, what's going on?
Forgive me for troubling you, sir.
Yeah, yeah.
You should be sorry.
Did I go in here already?
What's going on?
Just me?
Your commander?
Lord Supreme?
What?
Sir.
Yeah.
Salute me.
I want to see you hold that position.
Hold that position!
Sir.
Until I tell you to stop.
And if you're wondering...
Yeah, I do know where to go.
I'm just...
Running around everywhere.
Running around at the speed of sound.
Sir.
Thanks for that, boss.
Classic.
Oh, the little scientist.
You little scientist.
You little bitch ass scientist.
Yeah.
Coward.
What was that?
What, did you want to say anything?
No?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shake your head.
You didn't want to say... Yeah, you're quiet.
What about you?
Yeah?
Salute.
Salute me!
What's wrong with you?
God, where are your manners?
Why don't we hire any good scientists nowadays with good manners?
Who's sleeping over here on the job?
Wake up!
Every scientist needs to get kicked.
All you need to get whipped back into shape.
Keep working on our Metal Gear.
Keep working on it.
I think I did a good job.
Let's go out through its door.
Let's go explore the base.
A little bit more.
Actually, nah, it's okay.
I think I have a lot of...
I have more bullets and everything.
I think I'm okay for now.
I was going to say I need to explore, but that's just me being a loot goblin.
I've been trying to get so many things and it always tells me I'm full on ammo and everything, so I think we're okay.
Don't open that one.
Silent Hill Nurse.
Oh yeah, sorry.
It's the Shackle Holler.
Snake, I...
Hello there?
Paramedic, it's me.
Snake?
Oh, it's you.
For a minute there, I thought you were someone else.
Why are you so nervous?
You've seen this mask before, right?
Yeah, but it looks...
so cool.
So cool?
Cool.
You know, kind of like a Venusian.
A Venusian?
I mean, not the crab kind.
The other kind.
What?
Paramedic, do you really think a guy you've never seen before would suddenly call you on this frequency?
I know it sounds ridiculous, but still.
What if it was a being from another planet?
You can't rule out that possibility.
He looks so cool.
He should be the protag of his own game.
She's the Lulu.
So true.
Okay, you're disguised as Rikar.
Yep.
You ought to be able to pass for the real deal in that outfit.
You can go anywhere you want, and nobody's going to ask questions.
Yep.
But don't forget that you can't equip most of your weapons when you're in disguise.
So sad.
My Rikar of disguise.
Let's go get some love.
Ooh.
Oh,
Eva Kodak?
You think she'll be so scared of me?
Okay.
Your Rikar of disguise is complete.
Now they won't stop you no matter what you do.
Even if I punch someone in the face?
Yeah.
Really?
Really.
Why?
Rikar's just that kind of guy.
Rikar's such a freak!
Once you're disguised as Rikar, you can get into the west wing where Sokolov is being held.
Yeah.
To get to the entrance to the west wing, pass west through the main wing of the weapons lab and go through the connecting passageway.
Okay.
You can get into the main wing of the weapons lab from the southwest side of the second floor.
Southwest side of the second floor.
Head for the main wing.
Okay.
Alright.
We just, again, we just don't need anybody grabbing our crotch.
I wonder what the difference is.
I wonder.
Oh, oh, oopsie.
Who would do that?
Nobody.
Nobody would do that.
Otherwise it's a perfect disguise.
Okay.
There we go.
I need to see the models.
You know?
The character models.
Alright.
There it is!
The shagohide!
Oh my gosh.
There it is.
I
wanna go in.
I wanna go in.
There's the shagohide.
OG camera here is cool too.
Oh, let me try it.
Sorry.
We gotta go back for the cinema.
For the cinematics!
Okay.
Oh.
It looks exactly like how I got it.
I like how I see it's no Rex.
I see it's no Ray.
Actually, the shagohide is pretty ugly.
I'm not gonna lie.
But you know, whatever.
Whatever.
It's fine.
It's not a Metal Gear.
So, you know, it's not like we can be like, oh, it's so cute!
All the other Metal Gears are truly cute.
Hello.
But shagohide's kinda ugly.
What if I took off my mask in front of them?
Salute!
Yes.
Does Rykov, like, kind of sneak around hunched like that?
Alrighty.
Why are you taking it off, though?
I just like wearing a thong to get into character.
Maybe that's what Volgan feels.
That he's not wearing his thong.
What is that?
What about the Philosopher's Legacy?
I don't know anything about that.
What are you...
Are you trying to kill me?
Don't be a little liar.
What's the matter?
Afraid of some lipstick?
I know nothing.
I swear it.
No one but the Colonel knows of the Legacy.
I see.
No, don't!
Come on.
It's just a little bit of lipstick.
You gotta be more secure in yourself.
It's just some lipstick.
I'm eating my potato chip sticks, by the way.
Yeah, I was really not his color.
You're so right.
Who's there?
Ugh.
You're the man from the CIA.
I got a crumb in my throat.
What are you doing here?
I told you before, didn't I?
I'm going to get you out of here.
A man of honor, just like your commander.
After this, I'll get some water.
But I'm afraid you're too late.
What?
Too late?
Oh my god, Snake looks so good in this uniform.
You know what he looks like?
He looks like that commander guy from Nikkei.
In this outfit, he looks like the guy from Nikkei.
I don't remember his name, though.
To put it in technical terms, it's a composite range extension system for medium range ballistic missiles.
Anderson?
Maybe.
I don't remember his name.
The Shagahod was originally designed as a tank that could launch nuclear missiles from any type of terrain.
I saw a cosplayer of him at TGS even.
There was just one problem we couldn't figure out how to solve.
The ICBMs we have today are simply too big for the Shagahod to carry.
But the military would not hear of it.
They demanded a weapon that could launch a nuclear missile directly into the American homeland.
And he looks like a slug.
That is when I came up with the idea for Phase 2.
But there's no way you could load an ICBM onto the Shagahod.
So how do you do it?
By accelerating the Shagahod itself.
Accelerating it?
In Phase 2, a rocket booster unit is attached to the frame of the Shagahod.
The unit incorporates the same technology used in the Vostok rocket that sent Major Gagarin into space.
Look at him go!
Using this booster, the Shagahod can achieve a land speed of over 300 miles per hour.
But you need like so much.
That monster can go more than 300 miles per hour.
You need so much space for this.
It's not practical.
And from this state of accelerated motion, it launches a nuclear missile.
Who straps a rocket to a tank?
It acts like the first stage of a rocket.
Yes, precisely.
The range of the missile launched by the Shagahod thus increases from 2,500 miles to 6,000 miles.
6,000 miles.
That's enough to strike anywhere in the United States.
What the hell is your profile picture?
Not only that, with the Shagahod, there's no need to construct giant silos like the ones used to house ICBMs.
Oh.
All you need is a runway 3 miles in length or its equivalent.
All you need is about 3 miles.
And you can launch a thermal nuclear strike against any location in the United States from anywhere in the Soviet Union.
It cannot be detected by spy planes or satellites.
Okay, that's pretty bad.
It's a mobile fortress capable of deploying in secret and launching its payload at any time.
Yeah, that sucks.
It's not good.
That's so like...
I don't know.
It just doesn't seem so...
Why did they...
Turn down Grannon's idea and think this was better.
I don't understand.
But Vulcan is planning to mass produce them based on that prototype.
And deploy them all over the Soviet Union.
Yes.
And that's not the end of it.
He's going to ship them to Eastern Europe.
To Asia.
To all the countries of the Eastern Bloc.
Even worse, he intends to use the Shagahod as bait to format armed uprisings among dictators, ethnic insurgents and revolutionary groups throughout the Third World.
We came for the cute ghost babies and the fence builders.
He could start mass production tomorrow if he wanted.
The reason that tensions between East and West have settled into a cold war is because each side fears the other's power.
Deterrence.
The idea of using threats to keep one's enemy in check is the perfect word to sum up this state of affairs.
But...
the Shagahod goes far beyond the level of threat.
A weapon to surpass ICBMs.
It will make the concept of deterrence utterly meaningless.
If such a weapon is unleashed on the world it will not be long before all nations are engulfed in conflict.
The Cold War will end and the entire planet will be consumed by the fires of war.
Vulcan and the Shagahod will be at the center of it all.
Probably because the tech for legs wasn't quite there yet in the Warhouse on Rockets.
That's true.
It takes them a really long time to get...
to make wrecks.
That is true.
No.
It's not too late.
What do you mean?
We've still got a chance.
All we have to do is destroy the prototype and the whole facility before they can mass produce it.
But...
Just tell me what I need to do to destroy this place.
Alright.
The liquid fuel used in the rocket engine is stored in a tank.
If you can blow it up somehow...
Some C3 ought to be enough to blow the entire hangar to smithereens.
C3.
Someone stole the C3.
You mean that cutting edge plastic explosive?
It could be molded into any shape.
The bomb of the future.
Where can I get it?
There was some in the armory here, but it's gone now.
It was stolen by a female spy.
It was here a minute ago.
The door is truly hot.
No.
That's not her name.
Her name is Tatyana.
Tatyana.
She made her way in here by becoming Volgin's lover.
Look at her.
I thought she was your lover.
Mine?
No.
She is Volgin's lover.
He's like, I don't want anything to do with her after touching Volgin.
This is my lover.
My lover.
Who are they?
My wife.
They're in America.
His wife is so scary looking.
Now I remember.
Your family is in the custody of the CIA.
She has like the largest forehead ever.
How long has Tatyana been here?
What a beautiful family.
Only a few weeks.
This freak of a wife.
I can't wait to see her in Delta.
I'm so excited.
She said that Khrushchev sent her.
What did you just give her?
All of the experimental data for the Shagohod.
Apparently even like Kojima was just like, Yo, it is essential that you destroy the Shagohod.
Yo, Shinkawa-sama.
Shinkawa-san is pretty scary.
You should probably fix her.
And he was just like, Yeah, so?
I'm not going.
My mission is to rescue you.
Leave me.
Sokolov.
Khrushchev has abandoned me.
Snake just screamed eternally.
I cannot return to my country.
I would most certainly be sent to the gulags.
I need to see what she looks like.
What about the U.S.?
Yes, I once thought of that.
My family is waiting for me there.
But, even if I fled to the United States, I would once again find myself creating weapons of mass murder.
I would once again find myself creating weapons of mass murder.
Can you imagine if they...
144.75!
In the end, it doesn't matter where I go.
Can you imagine if they had like a game based off of Sokolov's skin?
He also becomes a scientist developing Metal Gears.
Aww, Sokolov.
Every day I help create things that should never be used.
Things that should never have existed in the first place.
Every day.
Without sleep.
Without a word of praise from others.
And my creations do not even benefit mankind.
This poor guy.
They are merely the tools of politicians.
All I wanted to do was build space rockets.
This is so sad!
But it was not to be.
The space race between America and Russia became the prey of politicians.
The space race and the arms race are one and the same.
Missiles, rockets,
and the space race are one and the same.
The space race
is not the only place where you can create and create more things.
I think that these are the and trying create and create and create
and make Something... see these crevices... this fabric does not feel right.
Oh, Volgen.
Oh my god.
I come here looking for Tatiana.
And what should I find?
But a greasy freebooter.
I love these cutscenes.
Oh no!
Oh my god.
Yes!
I think you see him.
Take it down.
That's why!
Paz, why?
Why couldn't you just watch from outside the door?
Absolute cinema.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Paz, I've never been a fairy in disguise.
What are you talking about?
Ew, he's a skinwalker.
I don't like this.
All the guys are dead on the ground.
All the guys are like...
I see why they call you the boss.
Yeah.
What was that?
Some kind of judo?
No, it's called CQC.
A basic form of close quarters combat.
He and I developed it together.
No.
Splendid.
I'll take it from here.
Oh, boy.
Oh, no.
Are you going to kill him?
No.
Of course.
Oh, I don't like this part.
But first...
It hurts.
Oh, I don't like this part.
I will make him pay for hurting Ivan.
Ivan.
Oh, I hate this.
It just hurts so much watching him get beat up.
Oh, Snake!
It's like...
It's like MGS4.
It's just so...
Oh, my god!
She's just punching him.
Awe, boss...
I also like seeing him a little bloody.
Ugh...
Oh my god.
He takes all of this and then also the torture scene.
It's insane.
No!
Snake!
Why don't you fight back, Snake?
Why don't you fight back?
Oh god, it's so... oh it's so gross.
It's so awful.
Oh Snake, how are you even still standing?
How do you still have teeth?
Just another Sunday for Solid Snake.
You're absolutely correct.
No!
No, that is not Solid Snake!
Bad end.
And that's the end of the game, guys.
GG.
He is dead.
The rest of the series never happens.
Oh...
It's so cool, love!
He's really taking it, though.
How can you do this to him?
I know you gave the data to someone.
I never did that.
You!
Sokolov?
Are you okay?
I guess he's dead.
Sokolov?
Oh god.
The sound design here is just...
Oh wait, here we go.
Do you like what you see?
I wonder if...
if that will change?
I am about to show you what hell is really like.
It would be so cool if that would change in Delta, considering they're gonna have you like...
Well then...
Let's get started.
Have your body get more scarred or whatever the more you get shot at.
What is your target?
Is it the Shagohod?
Or Sokolov?
Or maybe it's the Legacy?
Answer me!
Who is helping you?
Who let you in here?
Oh my health!
You're a tough one.
I'm a tough cookie.
But even you must have your limits.
No, no, no.
And I am a patient man.
Oh my god, I have to go to the bathroom again.
I'm sorry, I've been drinking so much coffee and tea.
Can we see now?
Yay!
Here's where the fun really begins.
You say this, you.
My body carries an electric charge of 10 million volts.
Let's see how you like this.
Snake, just hold out, Snake.
Snake...
Now answer me.
How much does the CIA know?
You won't get a word out of me.
Oh my gosh, not even Ocelot can watch this.
They're after my legacy, aren't they?
Your real target is the Philosopher's Legacy, isn't it?
I don't even know what that is!
Oh my god, Ocelot...
Doki doki!
Oh my gosh!
Yes, yes.
Let yourself go.
That's what I want to see.
Don't worry, Snake.
You're much cooler than Sokolov and Huey or...
I mean, sorry, Ocelot and, you know...
He's a Pikachu.
It's no use.
He's not going to talk.
He's been trained not to break.
Trained by me.
That bag is like...
Admit it!
We're after the location of the legacy!
The secret fund established by the three great powers during the two world wars.
That's what you're looking for, isn't it?
I don't know what that...
One hundred billion dollars divided up and hidden all over the world.
Ahhh!
And you're looking for a record of where all that money is hidden, right?
Oh my God!
He's doing that villain thing where he just explains everything.
He explains his whole plot.
Or his whole, like, scheme, you know?
The philosopher's legacy is safely in my possession.
Yeah, now I am!
Oh, really?
Okay, thank you!
Never think about it.
Ahhh!
What's that?
What's this?
A transmitter.
Who's responsible for this?
No, no.
I am.
I planted it on him to keep track of his movements.
Be careful, there's a spy in this room.
Yeah.
Just one, hopefully.
Anthony!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Cool.
If they knew where he was gonna be, they wouldn't have gotten themselves slaughtered.
Oh, do you want to know where the philosopher's legacy is?
Yeah, do you want to know?
You don't know what the philosopher's legacy is?
I must ask you to show me some proof that you and he were not in collusion.
It's a bunch of money.
Is that what you're looking for?
You wouldn't find it unless you look in the underground vault in the film Grasnagrad.
What do you want me to do?
Let's see.
Snake.
Cut out his eyes.
I don't like those blue eyes of his.
What?
There's nothing more important to a soldier than his eyes.
He hates that meme.
You made him a soldier, and now you will unmake him.
Of the guy with the big blue eyes with the arms crossed.
Not as big as the beautiful blue eyes.
He's all yours.
Ruin him.
Just as he did the cobras.
All the blue-eyed people in the room are like Don't do it.
Don't do it.
Yeah, he would hate Gojo Satoru.
So true.
Oh my god.
Ocelot, you are so weird.
He's like, nah, you should watch.
Why are you such a freak?
No, you need to watch this.
Check it out.
Oh my god.
No!
Stop!
What is it, Tanya?
He's suffered enough.
Well, well.
Hmm?
Why are you protecting him?
Stop pointing your fingers at my face.
That smell.
Yeah, smelly smell.
Smelly smell.
It smells smelly.
Tatiana.
Yeah?
You're the spy.
What?
What are you talking about?
On what grounds?
Don't look so suspicious, Eva, please.
I mean Tatiana.
Oh gosh.
I know that smell.
What's that smell?
It's the smell of a bitch.
Stop it.
Yeah.
Stop smiling.
No.
I have no interest in this woman.
And women, sorry.
I want to test her.
Vulcan is...
I'll let this be the judge.
This is like the freakiest room you'll ever see.
The freakiest freaks that will ever be together in a room ever.
Here we go.
Oh, just like with Sokolov.
There.
Satisfied now.
Oh god.
Well, that was refreshing.
Come.
We're going to my room.
Oh, oh.
He's just like...
She started crying.
I need to get to the bedroom stat.
Oh my god.
You are such a freak.
Watching this has made me realize something.
It's really not that bad.
Oh my god.
It's the ultimate form of expression.
Oh god.
The ultimate form of showing your love.
You got lucky this time.
But I'm going to use the Super Chat thank you.
The ultimate form...
of expression.
So romantic.
This freak, you freak, this freak, freak, freaky, freak, freak, freak, man, freak.
Boss, don't do it.
144.
144.75 Run!
144.75!
Do you still love me?
I prepared an escape route for us.
Go out and head west.
West, okay, west.
Pass underneath the connecting passageway and go north.
You'll find an open manhole there.
You're...
Quiet!
Go through the manhole down into the sewers.
The door at the north end of the sewers is unlocked.
Wait, did he just realize?
You can use it to get outside the fortress.
I've got your equipment.
He just noticed?
We'll meet up later.
Eva.
But I can't get too close.
You're too close to your cell.
You'll have to figure a way out of there yourself.
He's kind of dense.
I'll be honest though.
The first time I played this, it did take me a while to realize that they were both the same.
I'll be in touch.
I didn't know either.
I'll be honest.
And for a long while.
Not until up to here, but...
Ocelot, you freakishly freak zoid of a freak, utterly freakish freakery.
Phantom.
Phantom von Mito.
llegar aima pareja o a mia Oh, wait, hold on.
Thank you.
I see a light.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday,  Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, I see a light.
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday.
When is the dream sequence?
Why would you send that to me?
I got a fork.
Hell yeah.
Time to eat!
I don't want any bad.
I don't want this.
When is the...
Why is my aim so bad?
When was the dream sequence?
Wasn't it supposed to be...
Wasn't it supposed to happen?
Isn't there a dream sequence you can do in here?
Yeah, like...
Oh, you have to save in the prison.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Save and quit in the prison.
Yeah.
Save and quit.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I was like, wait a second.
I thought it would happen.
I'm gonna do a new file.
Turn the game console off right now.
All right.
And I have it as a new file, so if I ever want to come back to it.
Didn't you want to take a break?
I did.
I do have to go to the bathroom.
Snake?
Yeah?
Awe.
Snake?
My mouth hurts when I talk.
Awe.
Did you get cut up?
It feels like someone shoved me into a long war.
Paramedic, why are you so rude?
Do me a favor.
Tell me a story to take my mind off the pain.
Snake, have you ever heard of Renfield?
Is that a movie?
It's the name of a character.
He's locked up in a cell waiting for the master to return, eating the spiders that crawl along the walls.
Ugh, change the channel.
He waits and waits for ages.
Finally, just as he's beginning to forget whether he's human or not, the master comes for him, saying, the time has come.
Renfield is overjoyed.
Wait, isn't this?
The master spreads his huge wings and a gust of wind fills the cell.
Come on.
I don't want to hear this.
And there, standing before Renfield in human form was...
Dracula.
Exactly.
If you stay there too long, your old buddy Dracula is going to come and get you too.
That's why he has the bad dream.
So you'd better start thinking of a way out of there.
You'd better not leave me without someone to talk to.
Please, Snake, think.
There's got to be a way out of there.
I'll try.
That's why he has a bad dream.
Just let me know if you start having nightmares about Dracula.
I do.
Alright, give me one second.
Here, I'll let Johnny... you can watch him do his thing.
I'm going to go to the bathroom and then I'll restart my PS2.
BRB.
And I'm going to get some more tea.
Because I have... I need a hydration check.
I have no hydration if I haven't had hydration for like an hour and a half.
So...
So, BRB.
Yes, BRB.
Chow time.
Oh, my stomach.
Oh, God.
Oh, I can't hold it anymore.
It's coming.
It's coming out.
Here it comes.
Uh, still going.
Wow, I didn't think that was possible.
That's a record.
Will this even flush?
Oh, Jesus.
Ah.
Oh.
Hey.
Eat up.
Sorry about that, I'm back.
I had to feed my kitties too.
Okay.
How was Johnny?
Did you hear the play-by-play?
What do you mean the play-by-play?
Johnny had an episode?
Oh no, is he okay?
Johnny brought you food and set a new record.
You missed Johnny's record breaking too flush out.
Oh good lord.
Let's turn off the game.
Pretend that never happened.
Congrats on the new record.
It wasn't me!
It wasn't me.
Boom.
Nope.
Sorry, it's gotta like do all its funny things, you know.
This is gonna be fun.
Many new players haven't seen Guy Savage Nightmare because it's not an MGS3 HD.
Just remember to codec everybody afterwards.
Yes, yes, yes.
Alright.
Sorry, I will be skipping Snake Eater intro.
I'm so sorry!
What do you mean wow?
Have I got places to be?
I was thinking honestly about beating the game today but...
I decided I'll probably finish after this and then beat it next week.
I was gonna power on through it but since I'm feeling... I'm starting to get a little bit of a headache and I'm hungry so...
I think I'll just beat it next week.
Oh my god.
What do I...
Oh my god!
Metal Gear Rising!
What's happening to me?
I'm killing the police!
Oh my god!
Wow!
Oh my god.
It's so loud.
I'm destroying everything for real.
I'm destroying everything real.
Oh my god.
I just bust through the wall.
Oh my god!
Oh, I can't bust through the... I can bust through the walls.
Wow!
No!
I can't... I can bust through this.
I can bust through this.
I can bust through this but I can't bust through the bus.
Bust through the bus!
Never mind.
Stop the bomb!
I see more things are here.
Thanks for keeping coming...
Oh my gosh!
A 15 hour work day!
Is that what you just said?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, two!
Oh my god.
The more I kill, the more I thrive!
The more I kill, the more I crave!
Yes!
I'm becoming Super Saiyan!
Yeah!
They become slow-mo and I become crazy hack and slash.
You try to escape me?
Try to get out of my clutches?
I feel like I'm really destroying these guys.
But they just keep standing up.
They keep getting up.
I can't believe I've been a fan of MGS so long and never knew this existed.
Yeah.
Only in the...
It's in the subsistence.
Yeah, yeah.
I had a scary nightmare about Dracula, man.
Just a fever.
Yeah.
Don't talk about Dracula and then let Snake go to sleep, everybody.
He'll have nightmares!
There's so many things that you can miss in this game, especially if you like don't...
Like if you don't follow certain... what's it called?
Like if you like... if you don't follow...
Like for that, you have to save the game here and then stop playing here.
Or else you'll never get it.
No one believed me that it was real.
Oh!
I'm still fishing, thank you.
Thank you!
Back in England, we don't call stuff like that fine spirit.
We call it...
Sulfuric acid.
Ooh.
Imagine, if you will, your internal organs being slowly eaten away.
The smoke pours out of your mouth.
Really, Snake.
You shouldn't be touching that.
I'm not!
I'm not drinking!
A dream.
Well, how nice.
And here I thought I sat up all night worrying about you for nothing.
Okay.
Okay, Major.
I was holding this sword in my hand.
Snake, are you okay?
You're not going loony on me, are you?
Not at all.
I'll make it back no matter how much of that sulfuric acid they make me drink.
Okay, Major.
Good show.
You don't have to be so rude.
I'm sure you'll find a way out of there.
Yeah.
Dream a little dream of your own while you're waiting for work from me.
Dream a dream.
Oh, yeah.
There was a...
Oh, no.
That was to get out.
I don't want to do the 144.75.
Snake, what happened?
What do you think?
Yeah.
Are you not feeling well?
What do you think, huh?
No.
I'm feeling fine.
Paramedic.
I had the most amazing dream thanks to you.
Ah.
You didn't really dream about Drac.
Don't say it.
The last thing I need to know...
Ah!
It was surreal.
I was being attacked by a horde of weird human-like monsters.
What's wrong with me?
Don't say it.
It must be a form of persecution complex.
Probably triggered by extreme stress.
The external stimulus of the room is...
I've got a different theory.
I think it was caused by your pillow talk.
Ooh.
But I didn't...
Mm-hmm.
I'm sorry, Snake.
I didn't know you were that sensitive to it.
I mean, who'd have thought Drac...
Ah.
That just slipped out.
I swear.
Ah.
Come on, Snake.
Don't be mad at me.
All right.
I forgive you.
Really?
He's so forgiving.
Yeah.
Good.
I'm glad.
Snake, there must be a way out of there.
Don't get discouraged.
You'll find it.
I intend to.
Don't.
Bring it up.
I'm gonna ban the name Drac.
He who shall not be named in my chat.
So you guys can't...
Snake, you okay?
Eh.
Yeah.
I had a terrible dream.
No kidding.
What happened?
I don't want to think about it.
I was being attacked by monsters that...
I had a really horrible dream last night, too.
Not even sure if I was really me.
Oh, my gosh.
At least it was just a dream.
It's all over when you wake up.
I actually had a really horrible dream.
True.
Alucard.
When you think about it, the fact that you can imagine a situation worse than the one you're in now means life can't be all that bad.
I sure hope so.
Yeah.
I'm scared of talking about it in my dream.
Let me tell you about the absolute worst, most sickening nightmare I ever had.
Oh?
This isn't one for the kids.
Oh, my God.
Kids, plug your ears.
Okay.
So there's this big pile of crap, right?
It's shaped like a giant tank and it's walking around on two legs going on a rampage and stomping on people and houses and stuff.
And this giant turd is carrying the nastiest missiles you ever saw.
Like whenever it launches one of its turd missiles, whatever it hits, people, trees, buildings...
My hometown, my old school, my family, my girlfriend, old man John.
Metal Gear shit.
Everything in that turd's path turned into shit.
That's... pretty sick.
Good thing it was just a dream, huh?
Sir 4 in blue.
Yes, that's a good thing.
Y'all dnde?
Yeah.
Good, then let's get down to business.
Okay.
We feel better now.
Y'see Snake, people are just sacks of shit, and they're full of holes.
Fill them up with water and it's gotta come out from side to side.
Okay, maybe that was a bad example.
What I'm trying to say is, no matter what the situation, there's always a way out.
Don't throw in the towel yet.
Clear your mind.
Think it through.
Assess the situation.
You'll find a way to escape.
Sick and so silly.
Can we even reach Eva?
I don't think so.
Oh, we can!
Eva, do they drug the prisoners here with hallucinogens?
I don't think that's their style.
Why?
I had a pretty bad dream.
Aw, baby.
A little baby bad dream.
This monster that I'd never seen before was coming at me with a knife.
And I wasn't me.
I was something else.
That doesn't surprise me.
You're in a mild state of shock from all the pain and exhaustion you're going through.
When he says it like, I had a dream.
Maybe one day you'll learn to stop hiding yourself.
Sounds so sad.
I know how you feel, Snake.
What?
I'm a spy too.
Wait!
You realize it.
I mean...
But the fake you is eating away at the real you.
I'm not a spy.
The person you're pretending to be is becoming the person you are.
And the real you is screaming out from somewhere deep inside.
Eva is projecting?
That's what you saw in your dream.
Maybe so.
I'd sing you a lullaby or something, but unfortunately I don't know any.
So pick your favorite song and I'll sing it for you in your head.
Any song?
And you can have as many encores as you want.
Sounds fun.
It's a deal then.
I wish Snake would tell us his favorite song.
Good luck.
Thanks.
See that?
It's right now.
Snake is just laying in the bed all relaxed and you hear...
Beep, beep, beep.
So horrible.
That's a nightmare.
Time to eat.
I don't want it.
How do I throw it through the hole?
Why am I so bad at getting it through the hole?
Oh my god!
FPS?
Okay.
Oh.
I threw it pretty far.
I'm gonna use my fork and clank.
Clank, clank, clank, clank, clank, clank.
Bless you.
Clank, clank, clank, clank, clank, clank, clank, clank, clank, clank, clank, clank, clank.
My food's over there.
Uh oh.
How do I get the cutscene with him again?
I have to feed him some more?
Okay.
Reject three times.
That's what I thought.
I just couldn't remember.
I'm so hungry.
In game and in IRL.
Oh, snake.
You look so beat up.
You look so bad.
Are you okay?
It looks like you're wearing a little bow tie.
Oh yeah.
My dream?
Oh my gosh.
You guys, my dream was like serious.
Okay.
It's like, it was like really bad.
So I wasn't me.
And my mom wasn't my mom.
But I was like, I'm gonna do this.
But like, it felt like I was having like, like an out of, not an out of body.
It felt like I possessed like a, like someone or something.
I felt, and like, I wanted to do something.
And you know, like my, my, oops.
My mom was like, no, you can't do that.
And I was like, I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it.
And my mom, who's not my actual mom.
And I'm not actually me.
They were like, she was like, you're gonna do it.
I was like, no.
And I like, oh hell yeah, frog.
I ended up like, this is gonna sound so horrible.
I ended up murdering her.
Like, and I remember it was like in the bathroom.
And like, it was like the, like the glass shower door broke and everything.
I know.
It's so scary.
Right?
And then, and then the rest of the dream.
Was me like, being like, oh my gosh, I killed my mom.
And like, people being like, oh my gosh, she's dead.
We have to figure out who the murderer is.
And I'm like, oh my God, I'm going to jail forever.
That thing I wanted to do.
Well, I guess I'm never gonna do it because I'm going to jail forever.
And I woke up and I was so scared.
I thought it was a real thing that happened.
I was like, why?
What's going on?
I was so scared.
I felt like I possessed someone, someone else.
I was seeing it through their vision.
It was so scary.
Oh my God, can you imagine?
I tell you this.
And I'm like, it'll never happen, obviously.
And then, like, you know, like five years, you see me in the news, mint phantom.
Murderer.
Oh, way.
He gave me a fish, though.
Big-Eyed Trevally.
Oh, oops.
Huh?
Hmm?
Well, streaming from Prison, here we go.
New stream idea.
Becoming a murderer.
Hey, you're not such a bad guy after all I guess.
Not all Americans are dogs.
You mean it?
Yeah.
You wanna Kiss?
You know?
You know, before the war started, I used to live in America.
I even had a wife and a kid.
Yeah, I was your kid.
You must be pretty lonely.
Oh, Snake, what are you?
What are you?
Yeah, I am pretty lonely.
Really lonely.
I can fix that.
What's your kid's name?
Johnny!
Johnny, nice ring to it.
Really?
You like it?
Russian Johnny.
Well if you say so, I'll believe you.
You seem lonely.
Actually, my name is Johnny too.
Johnny!
Oh my gosh, your wife looks normal.
Kind of.
All the first born sons in my family are called Johnny.
Johnny looks so handsome in this picture.
My dad's a Johnny and my son's son will probably be a Johnny too.
144.75 The whole clan of Johnnies.
Why do we have a cold war anyway?
The whole clan of Johnnies.
Our two countries used to be such good friends.
Right.
Yeah, I hear ya.
I just want to see my family again.
No, Johnny.
Must be rough.
Too bad he's not a Mike.
Not as rough as you have it though.
Here.
What's that?
I filched them from your equipment when the Colonel wasn't looking.
You stole my stuff?
Oh, thank you for the...
It's the least I can do.
Are those the ones that knock you out?
Hey.
Come here, buddy.
Don't suppose you could let me out of here?
Huh?
I can't do that.
Hey, don't you go getting any funny ideas.
This guy was definitely bullied.
If you try to escape, I'll have to shoot you.
No.
Okay.
I've said too much.
I gotta go.
Raiders?
Oh, I didn't say thank you.
Hello.
Who raided?
Thank you so much for the raid.
Hello, everybody.
I'm MintPhantom.
I'm a custom-made VTuber.
Ducky, thanks for the gifted.
We're playing my favorite game series of all time ever, ever, ever, ever, ever.
Metal Gear Solid.
We're on...
This is the third game, but it's the first in the timeline.
So, you know.
Let's eat up real quick.
We got a rat here to eat.
Don't watch me eat this rat.
Oh.
Tasty.
Murphy!
Thanks for the time gifted.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Hold on.
This way.
Can I use it?
Use it.
Snake, use it.
Snake.
There we go.
Yeah!
Okay.
One forty-four.
That's seven five.
It was seven five, right?
Yippee!
I didn't kill him by the way.
I knocked him out.
Who's calling me?
Sir Streak, thanks for the thank you food!
Did you manage to escape?
Yeah, I'm out.
Be careful.
In your present state, you're practically naked.
I know.
You don't have a single decent weapon and you'll never survive in a battle.
Okay.
I got my fist.
Take some time and pull yourself together.
Eva says she's recovered your equipment, so rendezvous with her as soon as possible to get your gear back.
Got it.
As soon as I leave this area, I'll save.
Use the escape route Eva set up for you.
Go down into the sewers through the manhole in the northwest section of Groznygrad.
I know where that is.
Start out by exiting the holding cells and heading northwest.
Northwest.
Goodnight, Johnny.
Whatcha got here?
Smoke grenade.
Sorry, I thought I heard someone else, but it's my own foots...
My own feet are scaring me.
Really feel...
Oh my god!
How did you get up so fast?
No.
No, no, no.
How did you get up so fast?
Gosh!
Um...
Anyway...
Six spray doesn't last long.
Oh really?
I thought it lasted longer.
Camera.
Kero-tan.
Um...
I leave through...
Wait.
Is he up again?
No.
Leave through there.
But let's grab stuff first.
Oh!
Oh hell yeah, mariko!
Oh la la!
You can't keep Johnny down.
Viewers are saying goodbye to the streamer.
Johnny...
I'm gonna have to keep knocking him out.
Take a photo?
I have to be fast.
Oh.
Yeah!
Nice.
It's taking a really long time to save.
Um...
Do you think he's awake yet?
No, he's still down.
Thank you!
Um...
Where haven't I gone?
I just want to get him down...
Oh, that door over there, right?
Oh wait, no, that's right.
I think I can leave.
I think I'm good actually.
Yeah, yeah, I'm good.
We can leave.
No wait.
I didn't go in here.
Just kidding.
We can leave.
It's just another bathroom.
Oh my goodness.
We are...
Actually...
I do want to go in here real quick.
Because I...
I saw this stuff under here.
Okay.
Torture room?
Oh, I missed the torture room.
Where is that?
Okay.
In here.
Oh, that's right, that's right.
Uh...
Nastiness is in here?
So gross.
Something on the bed.
It wouldn't let me get...
Alright!
Alright, alright.
Do you want to save?
Yeah, I want to save.
So next time...
We come back, all we do...
We escape.
We...
Go through the jungles once again.
Oh yeah, there is a little bit more jungle.
Because we have to go into the cave.
And find Eva.
We head back.
Grozny grad.
We...
Destroy...
We attach some C3s.
And then...
We got our big old fights.
And that's it.
So we will do that next week.
You can see how clean your river is.
Oh yeah!
Wait, when does the river happen?
River is...
When do I get...
When does that happen?
I can't remember.
We will figure it out.
We will see it.
Hey snake, have you ever seen my mother was a teenage spider queen from Mars?
Hell yeah.
I can't say that I have.
Neither have I.
I took a sip expecting her to like talk for more.
And she is just like...
Nope.
Well...
I want to keep playing.
But...
We will save the rest for...
We will save the rest.
How do you get more gas spray?
How do you even like...
Replenish that?
Because I have definitely used it before.
Um...
I want to play more but...
We will wait...
We have just a little bit left.
And I will finish it next week.
And... yeah.
I'm gonna go take that guy down.
Watch me do it.
Oh.
Can I not CQC?
Can I not flip him?
Just attack him.
Just...
Why can't you just do it normally?
Why can't I CQC?
That's so funny.
Kill me, kill me, kill me.
Kill me, kill me.
What if I just run?
What the?
Oh my god, that guy just came out of a hole.
Did you see that?
Where does that go?
Where did you come from?
Did you guys see that guy come out of this hole?
No way.
No?
I'm in a hole.
Idiot.
Will I look down?
Oh, hold on.
How do I use it?
What the?
I'm eating him.
I'm eating this guy.
Oh my god.
I'm eating this man.
I'm a monster.
I just ate him alive.
So funny.
I could've killed him by a fork.
Death by a fork.
What?
This guy actually goes to another area?
That's wild.
How did he...
Why was he in there?
Why was he in?
In this pipe.
You know?
No way.
This is where Kerotan is.
That's so funny.
She's armed to the fork.
Activated level 1 alarm.
That's the highest.
Oh.
She's a man-eater.
Man-eater.
I can't believe I'm still playing.
I need to stop.
Thank you guys.
We will have the finale next week.
I don't know if my heart is ready.
But we will have that.
I'm very excited.
After Snake Eater.
I don't think I'll go quite into 4 immediately.
I think I'll go from 3 to 4 immediately.
I might take a break.
Maybe I'll do like...
I don't know.
How long is...
I think I looked it up for like Ghost Babble.
I might be able to do it in one stream.
You know.
Just to get a new game in.
And...
I don't know.
I don't think I'll be playing portable ops.
I don't know about that.
But...
I don't know.
We'll see.
But...
Watch the Poops movie version.
So true.
I might do like Ghost Babble.
I might do Acid.
Just so I can cross them off my list.
And have a full completed...
Full completed game.
And then...
I know it's kind of out of order.
It's kind of random to do them in between.
But...
Isn't every stream Ghost Babble?
Stop!
Oh yeah!
We have Snake's Revenge as well.
So...
Gotta get all the...
Gotta get all the rest of the games off my...
So people can stop bugging me about it.
And be like, oh well you've never played Ghost Babble before.
Alright.
Well you've never played Snake's Revenge before.
Yeah!
They're on the list!
I'm getting to them.
You know, eventually.
But we'll finish this next week.
Same day, same time as this week.
And yeah!
Fake fan!
Yeah.
Thank you guys for joining me today!
I hope you guys had fun.
What a silly, silly game.
And I will see you guys next time for the completion.
And...
Thank you for more Snake.
Thank you for five months, Neko.
Thank you guys!
I'm gonna go get dinner.
And if you haven't eaten, I suggest you eat.
And...
Get some rest.
Oh!
I have to put my desk mat in the laundry.
Thank you!
Oh!
And my schedule for this coming week.
I'm still waiting on some stuff for the weekend.
So the weekend will be...
Friday and Saturday will be a little tentative.
Um...
I think I'm not streaming Saturday.
Thanks for the stream!
Thank you!
But...
Friday I'm not sure.
It depends on... I don't know when I can stream.
Because of like, rehearsal and stuff like that.
And...
I'm gonna be performing at Vmuse...
And it's Malaysia so it's like...
Totally opposite side of the world.
I'm probably gonna be...
I have to see what time they do...
Sound checks and all that stuff.
So...
Yeah, it's a bit shorter, it's a bit less streams this week, but I'm taking two days off, sorry.
But yeah, I will have my schedule up soon.
Tonight.
Thank you guys, thank you, thank you, thank you again!
Bye bye, bye bye, bye bye, bye bye, see you next time!
Bye bye, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Bye snake!
Everybody say bye snake, everybody say bye snake.
Bye bye!
They can still hear me, oh my gosh.